we'll
hear arguments
in number 73 1766
the united states of america against
nixon
[Applause]
and
the cost petition
richard m nixon against the united
states mr jawarski
there has been a request for additional
time
and court advanced that additional time
of one half hour i understand
that's correct correct and we'll be
allowed to each side then
we will not interrupt the argument with
any recess we'll go right through until
we finish
whenever you're
ready and they please the court
on march 1st last a united states
district court grand jury sitting here
returned an indictment against
seven defendants
charging various offenses
including among them a conspiracy to
defraud the united states
and also
to obstruct justice
john mitchell one of the defendants
was a former attorney general of the
united states and
also chairman of the committee to
re-elect the president
another h.r haldeman was president chief
of staff
another john ehrlichman was assistant to
the president for economic for domestic
affairs
the others were either on the present
staff
or held responsible positions on the
re-election committee
in the course of its deliberations the
grand jury
voted unanimously with 19 members
concurring
that the course
of events
and the formation and continuation of
the conspiracy
was such that president nixon among
a number of others
should be identified
as an unindicted co-conspirator
and the bill of particulars to be
filed in connection with the pre-trial
proceedings
now although this
particular decision and determination on
the part of the grand jury occurred in
february it was
a well-kept secret
for uh two and a half
months
a grand jury of course knew it the
members of the prosecution staff do it
it was done so to avoid affecting the
proceedings in the house judiciary
committee
and it was so kept during this two and i
had these two and a half months until it
became
necessary
to reveal it
as a result of the president's motion to
force the subpoena
as i will indicate subsequently in my
argument
now to obtain additional evidence
which the special prosecutor has good
reason to believe
is in the possession of and under the
control
of the president
and which it is believed by the special
prosecutor is quite important
to the development
of the government's proof of the trial
in the united states versus switzerland
the special prosecutor on behalf of the
united states moved for a sabina dukas
taken
and it is the subpoena here in question
the district court ordered the subpoena
to issue returnable on may the 2nd
and the subpoena of course called for
the production of
tape recordings in advance of september
the 9th
1972 which is a trial date
and this was done to allow time for
litigation in the event litigation was
to ensue
over the production of the tapes
and also for transcription
and authentication
of any tape recordings
that were produced in response to the
screen
on april 30th
the president released to the public
and submitted to the house judiciary
committee 1216
pages of edited
edited transcripts of 43 conversations
dealing with watergate
portions
of 20
of the subpoenaed conversations
were included among the 43
then on may the first the president by
his council filed
a special appearance
a formal claim of privilege
and a motion to cross the subpoena
now for
the united states to conduct a full and
appropriate hearing on a motion to quash
the subpoena
it became necessary
to reveal the grand jury's
finding
regarding the president
and this was first done by the special
prosecutor calling on
the chief of staff general alexander
haig
and the president's council mr sinclair
and advising them of what had occurred
two and a half months prior
and then on the following morning
advising judge zurich of what had
occurred in camera
and pointing out the necessity
of this being
used in connection with the arguments on
the motion of quash because of their
relevance and the necessity of these
matters being
made a part of the proceeding
now the special prosecutor joined
counsel for the president and urging
that tomorrow be
heard in camera
which was done
three of the defendants had joined
special prosecutor in
moving for the subpoena
all of the defendants
at the time of argument and camera
to judge sirica
opposed the motion to quash
i don't see the relevancy of the
fact that the grand jury indicted the
president as a co-conspirator to the
legal issue
as to the duty to deliver the
results to the tape that the safini that
you
are asking the only relevance
mr justice
lies in it being necessary to show
under rule of 17c that there is some
relevance to the material that we were
seeking to subpoena
and 17c presupposes
running against the party
and the president is no party he's not a
defendant in one of these cases that's
correct sir but it was also felt it
would be necessary to show why
in order to prove this uh
conspiracy
and in order to provide all of the links
in the conspiracy it was deemed
necessary to show
that the president was named as an
unindicted co-conspirator and also the
disproven i thought that was primarily
just for the
knowledge information
of the house judiciary
no sir that is not correct sir it became
very important mr justice for us to have
that as a part of the proceeding so that
we could use the various links in the
testimony
so as to show that the conversations
were such as to make one admissible as
against the co-conspirator the grand
jury sent it to the
house committee didn't the grand jury
sent nothing of an accusatory nature to
the house committee notion
what the grand jury sent to the house
committee was the evidence that had been
accumulated
and it very carefully excised from it
anything
by way of the grand jury's
interpretation or anything along that
line miss justice
now in its opinion an order of may 20th
the district court
first still be here mr jawarski whether
or not the president had been named as
an unindicted co-conspirator but that
simply gives you another string to your
bow isn't that about it it's true that
it admits some evidence that would
otherwise not be uh admissible right but
uh
even had the president not been named
uh you would still
have subpoenaed at least part of this
material there's no question about that
it'll be uh
you'd still be here that's right you're
not that's right so but in order to
present the full picture in order to
present
that also was a part of it
[Applause]
mr court denied a motion to quash and a
motion to expunge ahead ultimately no
one uh no one yet has ever suggested
that if you're in a criminal trial
conspiracy trial
and some evidence is offered of an out
of court statement of someone who's
alleged to be a co-conspirator that it's
enough for the prosecution to then show
that the grand jury had named him as a
co-conspirator
no that never gets you it will never get
done over the
and we don't so content well then that
was the point of your that was the
direction of your no this was his
connection this was in connection with
the subpoenaing of this evidence mr
justice in other words this was in
connection with showing that we had the
right to this evidence well i understand
that yes sir but and that was the point
you do not suggest that that's all you
need to show is that it no sir or of
course not you don't suggest that the
grand jury uh finding is binding on the
court or not
i do suggest that it makes a prime of
facial case
and i think under the authorities it so
does but let me understand this mr
speaker you don't suggest that your
right to this evidence depends upon
the president's having been named as an
unindicted pronouncer
and so for the purposes of our decision
we could
uh play that fact
that's why did we what i was really
doing and pointing to that well couldn't
yes
uh primarily was in order to show
a reason for
the grand jury's action
they there's also before this court a
motion to expunge
the
act of the grand jury
in naming the president as an unindicted
co-conspirator and i was trying to lay
before the court the entire situation
that warranted that action
mr jawoski
as i understand your brief you go beyond
what
you have addressed so far
i think you say that uh the mere fact
that the president was named as an
unindicted co-conspirator
forecloses
his claim of privilege
well we certainly made any one of your
briefs we certainly make that as one of
the points which i intend to discuss at
a later point that reduces him
in and of itself to the status of any
other person accused of crime
i don't say that it forecloses what i
think we suggest is that it does present
a situation here
that should not make the application of
executive privilege appropriate
we do say that
but only promotion
promise you that's correct
but when you get to the matter mr
justice powell of balancing interests
we do feel that that particular
situation is a factor that is important
and this is why we laid stress on it
the court's order of course was to
deliver to the court the originals of
all subpoenaed items
as well as an index and an analysis of
those items
together with taped copies of those
portions of the subpoena recordings for
which transcripts have been released to
the public by the president on april
thirtieth
now this case presents for review the
action lower court now may i before i
get to the jurisdictional points
briefly state
what we consider to be a bird's eye view
of this case
now invest in almost 500 pages of briefs
when boiled down this case really
presents one fundamental issue
who is to be the arbiter of what the
constitution says
basically this is not a novel question
although the factual situation involved
is of course unprecedented
there are corollary questions to be sure
but in the end after the rounds have
been made
we return to face these
glaring facts that i want to briefly
review
for the final answer
in refusing to produce the evidence
sought by sabrina dukastem and the
criminal trial of seven defendants
among them
former chief aides and devotees
the president invokes the provisions of
the constitution
his council's
brief
is replete
with references to the constitution as
justifying his position
and in his public statements as we all
know the president has embraced
the constitution as offering him support
for his refusal to supply
the subpoenaed
tapes
now the president may be right in how he
reads the constitution
but he may also be wrong
and if he is wrong
who is there to tell himself
and if there's no one
then the president of course
is free to pursue
his course of erroneous interpretations
what then becomes of our constitutional
form of government
so when counsel for the president and
his brief states
that this case goes to the heart of our
basic constitutional system we agree
because in our view
this nation's constitutional form of
government is in serious jeopardy
if the president
any president
is to say that the constitution means
what he says it does
and that there is no one
not even the supreme court
to tell him otherwise
the president
went to a court he went to the district
court
with his motion to quash and then he
filed a cross petition here
he's not uh
he's asking the court to say that his
position is correct as a matter of law
is he not
he's saying his position is correct
because he interprets the constitution
that way right correct and he's asking
he's submitting his position to the
court and asking us to agree with it he
went first to the district court and
he's
petitioned in this court he's not
he has himself in invoked
the judicial process and he is
well that's not that's not entirely
correct mr justice well didn't he file a
motion to cause the subpoenas
sir he has also taken a position that we
have no standing in this court to have
this issue heard as a matter of law he's
asking
he's making that argument to a court so
that's a matter of constitutional law he
is correct so so that of course this
court could then not pass upon the
constitutional question of how he
interprets the constitution if his
position were correct that i had as a
matter of law if his position is correct
and he is the sole judge that's right
and he's asking this court to agree with
that proposition as a matter of
constitutional law
but what i'm saying is if he is the sole
judge and if he's to be considered the
sole judge and he is an error in his
interpretation
then he goes on being an error in his
internal and this court will tell him so
that's what this case is about isn't it
well that's what i think the case is
about yes sir he's submitting himself
to the judicial process in the same
sense that uh
that you are
is that not so much well
i can't see you take one position and he
takes another well mr chief justice and
in my view frankly it is a position
where he says the constitution says this
and nobody is going to tell me
what the constitution says because up to
this point
up to this point he says that he and he
alone is a proper one to interpret the
constitution
now there's no way to escape that
because the briefs
definitely point that out time after
time
i think this matter may be one of
semantics each of you is taking a
different position on the basic question
and each of you is submitting
for decision
to this cart
well we started maybe sir we start with
a constitution that does not contain the
words executive privilege is that right
that's right sir
so why don't we go on from there all
right
that is a very good beginning point but
of course other things that need to be
discussed too and as much as they've
been raised
perhaps it would further narrow the area
if
as i take it from your briefs you do
emphasize there is no claim
here
of
typical military secrets or diplomatic
secrets
or what in the burr case were referred
to as state secrets
none of those things are in this case is
that right that is correct
and we do point to the authorities to
show that there is a difference in the
situation here
i do think that it's proper as
much as i regret to have to do it
the point that
the president's interpretation
of what his actions should be
and this particular set of circumstances
as one that really requires judicial
intervention perhaps more so than a
normal one would
i think that we realize that there is at
stake
the matter of the supplying of evidence
that relates to
excuse me two form of close aids and
devotees
i think we're aware of the fact that the
president had publicly stated
that he believed that these two
aides of his mr alderman mr erkman would
come out all right in the end
added to that the fact that
the president has a sensitivity of own
involvement is also a matter that calls
for the exercise of
the question to which mr justice douglas
alluded as one that is somewhat unusual
turning now to jurisdiction
before the court are the two questions
of
in the statutory jurisdiction the court
directed
the parties to prove an argument
mr jaworski at this point to help me
over one hurdle
do you feel that the mandamus case as
such is here
i i search your yes we do sir i search
your petition for certiorari in vain to
find even a mention of it
and uh
i wondered it's a political question but
the uh what is your position position
that the issues in any event are here
yes whether the case is yes or no
we say it's here not only because of the
appeal itself but also because of
petition for maintainment now we did
mr justice discussed that in one of the
briefs
now it may be that it wasn't uh
originally when we filed the
the uh
the original brief on jurisdiction
you mentioned it in your second brief on
the merits yes but not at all in your
petition for search
it was in the footnote uh
on page two
of the petition for rhetoricary
justice
well i would think so but there really
is no issue between the parties here on
the issue of jurisdiction i mean there's
no no argument that's between the
parties on it and while of course the
parties can't agree on it i must say
that on three different bases the
jurisdiction does exist as we see it now
i'm not yet getting to the question of
the intra-executive matter that has been
raised
but i am discussing now the statutory
basis of jurisdiction
and
[Applause]
but to answer your question directly sir
this uh is correct we are
standing upon not only the matter that
this is an appeal that properly had been
in the court of appeals
and for that reason has been moved up
here properly
under
12541
we also say that
the court has jurisdiction over the
petition and cross petition under 12-4-1
because they present for review all
questions
raised by the petition by the
president's petition for rid of ann
dallas
and then we also say that uh in addition
to that the all rights act gives us
court jurisdiction
uh to proceed of course if uh in a
mandamus action uh judge sarika would be
the party respondent
and he's not a party in this case and
he's not represented by council here is
he
uh as far as i know he's not no sir in
fact i'm sure
the mandamus would be uh nixon versus
soreka would it not
but it was brought up by the president
and uh their petition for mandamus
that's right
yeah that's the way it got into this
court raises the same questions actually
that were raised on the matter that we
brought upon what was the chronology
the notice of appeal
from judge circa's order uh was the
first step taken to get to the court of
appeals was it that's i believe right
sir and while while that was pending
then i gathered the president's petition
for mandamus was right sir yes and then
the last step was that you filed
the petition
to bypass right
and that petition of ipad
applied i gathered to whatever case was
pending in the court of appeals that's
correction at that time the case pending
was both the appeal from judge sirica's
office
and the president
correct you feel there are not two cases
no so they raise the same questions yes
you could bring each up separately if
you so chose could have seen either two
cases
but they in as much as they present the
same questions it occurred to us that it
was appropriate to rely upon the
jurisdiction
as
to both of them
except i would suggest again that
with respect to the mandamus action one
of the parties isn't here in court
represented by council
he is the party respondent
well it is uh
i don't have the record before me but i
must say that uh in
and i will not make an outright
representation that judge zurich is and
that's why i hesitated a few minutes ago
was made a party after all it was
brought up by the president
but uh i am advised if i know it just
passed me i missed a lot of error that
judge soreka is a part of the leprosy
who represents him here i don't know of
anyone representing him here
does he has he filed any brief or made
an appearance at all in any sense
so far as i know not
all right
well if you're right
order was an appealable order that's
correct if you're correct in that
submission do we ever have to reach any
issues raised by the mandate no we would
not we were pointing out that the
jurisdiction arrests on a three-pronged
basis
but the grand davis is not your action
it's not no sir and you're not obliged
to depend on it that's correct sir
uh we however were pointing out that the
same issues really were raised by if the
petition is properly before the court
[Applause]
now
if there are no further questions on the
matter of statutory jurisdiction i would
like to
pass to the intra-executive dispute
first
we recognize of course that jurisdiction
cannot be waived and nothing that is
presented here is with the idea of
suggesting even remotely that there is
any wavelet with respect to the
questions of jurisdiction
but we do say that the contention that
there is
an uh intra-executive dispute and that
for that reason this court cannot pass
upon these questions is is not sound
before discussing the cases however i
think that it would be appropriate for
us to undertake to place this and the
right perspective
let me say first that
we stand upon two bases first that
the actually the orders that were
entered creating the office of the
special prosecutor and delineating his
authority
even the original order at the time that
my predecessor was acting as special
prosecutor had to force an effect of law
we also point to the fact that the
arrangement made itself
with the acting attorney general that i
made
if i may point to it and one reason i
have no reticence in discussing the
facts is because the facts are
undisputed it's been no dispute raised
as to just what actually transpired
the
situation is one of the arrangement
itself
which the acting attorney general points
to
uh with respect to respect to the matter
of independence having been discussed
by him
with the president
thus meaning that the president himself
had approved
uh the setting up
of this particular office and the rights
and the responsibilities that it has
under the charter
now let me we set this out in the
appendix of course pointing precisely to
what
the authority and the responsibilities
and obligations of the
special prosecutors are
one of the expressed duties that's
delegated to the special prosecutor is
that he shall have full authority
for investigating and prosecuting
among others allegations involving the
president and the delegation of
authority
express the states in particular
the special prosecutors shall have full
authority to determine
whether or not to contest the assertion
of executive privilege
or any other testimonial privilege
now in instance of
my appointment unlike the appointment
that had been made prior there too there
was an amended order
and it referred to assurances given by
the president to the attorney general
that the president will not exercise his
constitutional powers to affect the
charge of the special prosecutor
or to limit the independence
that he's hereby given
and that he will not be removed
from his duties except for extraordinary
improprieties on his part and without
the president's first consulting the
majority and the minority leaders and
the chairman and ranking minority
members of the judiciary committees to
the senate and house of representatives
and ascertaining that their consensus is
in accord with the proposed action
and then
that the jurisdiction of the special
prosecutor
will not be limited without the
president's first consulting with such
members of congress
and ascertaining that their consensus is
in accord with his proposed action
now
at the time it's not important what does
consensus mean unanimous
no sir it had been interpreted by the
acting attorney general in conversation
as uh
meaning six of eight
i take it
uh when you make reference to this you
are in effect
suggesting that your position is
certainly different than if a united
states attorney were
prosecuting this case that's correct sir
i think we have a what might be termed
the quasi-independent status
and where
there were delegated
to this particular office of performance
of certain functions and there's no
reason why the president couldn't have
delegated those to us
as a matter of fact when
yes sir for instance as a comptroller of
currency he has a status somewhat
similar to that and we know that their
suits brought between the department of
justice and the comptroller yeah just
the other day i have trouble with your
position being similar to the u.s
attorney because the united attorney is
absolutely under the thumb of the
attorney general well i didn't say that
i what i meant was that we had an
independent status that was really
different from the status of the united
states attorney
i thought that was the way i answered
the question
now
i should say that
it's interesting when the the case of uh
nixon versus sirica was before
the court of appeals
uh professor charles allen wright who
was then arguing that case
and who was not on the original brief
but i observed
on the reply brief filed on behalf of
the president
at that time arrogant
with respect to the
particular office of the special
prosecutor now in this instance we have
a division of function within the
executive in that my friend mr cox
referring to archibald cox
has been given absolute independence
it is for him to decide
whom he will seek to indict
it is for him to decide to whom he will
give immunity
a decision that ordinarily would be made
ordinarily would be made at the level of
the attorney general or in an important
enough case at the level of the
president
but the president's present counseling
and his motion to quash
as he does here except the words used
are different but the effect is the same
is contending to the court that the
president has the right to determine
who
when
in and with what information
individuals shall be prosecuted
nixon against the rica was different in
that
uh
the parties there
were the grand jury on the one hand
represented to be sure by the special
prosecutor but the grand jury which is
an adjunct of the
judicial branch of government on the one
hand uh
and the uh chief executive on the other
and uh here now that an indictment has
been returned
uh
the two parties are both members of the
executive branch is that
not correct that there is that
difference yes but the independent yes
sir that is correct but i don't think
it's a a
distinction as to the substance as to
the subject you are a member you're a
united states and people the united
states i mean represent
you are
not a member of the judicial branch
unlike the grand jury and
nixon against sarika you're a member of
the executive branch of government are
you not
that's correct sir yes and there is that
difference there's that difference yes
but i don't think crucial description to
which i pointed to which i pointed as to
the independent status
of the independent executor
would be any different in the sirica
case as it would be in this case and i
was barely
no you're if anything more independent
than uh mr cox flies under the
regulation that's correct sir but that
doesn't really go to the question that i
raised yes
i i realize that
now uh may i however
indicate
very briefly and i know this is an
important question but i do feel that
the facts ought to be before the court
in detail
indicate just what did transpire with
respect to how these
particular regulations this order was
interpreted by
the president's acting attorney general
and also
by
the attorney general designate
and also by the president himself and by
the president's chief of staff general
haye
mr bork
in hearings at a time when congress was
pressing the bill of an independent
special prosecutor
testified that although it is
anticipated that mr jaworski will
receive cooperation from the white house
in getting any evidence he feels
he needs to conduct investigations and
prosecutions
it is clear and understood on all sides
that he has the power
to use judicial processes to pursue
evidence if disagreement should develop
it was further pointed out
you're quoting from whom and what acting
uh acting attorney general borg's
testimony in the house
and
on one occasion after i had been
appointed and on in connection with the
hearings on
the bill to establish an independent uh
prosecutive congressional act thank you
lenny further said i understand and it
is clear to me that mr jaworski can go
to court and test out and these are the
important words and test out any refusal
to produce documents on the grounds of
confidentiality
and
attorney general saxby
then a designate
who was also present at the time that
this matter was discussed and at the
time that i accepted responsibilities
testified that
i had the right to contest an assertion
of executive privilege
and stated that i can go to court at any
time to determine that
now the president himself
as we point out in our brief
and announcing the appointment of a new
independent prosecutor stated
that uh
to the nation
that he had no greater interest than to
see that the new special prosecutor has
the cooperation from the executive
branch
and the independence
that he needs to bring about that
conclusion
of the watergate investigation
president chief of staff at the time
that this appointment
was accepted
and at the time that the new regulations
were then drafted by the acting attorney
general
had assured me and this
is a part of the record
because
a letter was written at the request of
senator hugh scott
to the white house as a result of
discussions that he had with general
hague
in which i sent a copy of the testimony
that i had given to the congressional
committees to the white house so it
would be fully aware of it and the
receipt of it was acknowledged without
any change in in the testimony
so i had been assured of the right to
judicial process
and by him after he had reviewed the
matter with the president and came and
told me that i would have the right to
take the president to court
and that these were the key words in
this arrangement and that the right
would not be questioned
of course this
independence that was given to the
special prosecutor actually was but an
echo of public demand
and if i may be
permitted to say so it was only basis on
which
after what had occurred and a
predecessor had been discharged
it was only basis on which the special
prosecutor could have felt that he could
come in and serve and undertake to
perform these functions
now it's important i think to observe
that counsel for the president
in his brief by accepting the
proposition that the president and the
attorney general general can delegate
certain executive functions to
subordinate officers
implicitly
has conceded so we think the validity of
the regulations delegating
process tutorial powers to the special
prosecutor
the regulations specifically provide as
you will notice from the appendix and we
have set them out the attorney general
will not countermind
or interfere with a special prosecutor's
decisions or actions this is also a part
of the charter
[Applause]
just to argue as
has been done in these briefs that the
separation of powers precludes accords
from entertaining this action because it
is the exclusive prerogative of the
executive branch
not the the judiciary to
to determine whom to prosecute on what
charges and with what evidence we think
misses the point
what has evolved from the regulations in
our view is a prosecutorial force with
certain exclusive responsibilities
and this is why i say that to some
degree it could be described as a
quasi-independent agency
it's not
unlike our situation is the case
we alluded to a few minutes ago decided
by the court just a week or so ago
it's not unlike the case of the
secretary of agriculture versus the
united states this is the first time
that there has been an action brought by
one member of the executive branch
against another official in the
executive branch
and we refer to these cases in our
briefs in detail
now
i want to make it clear that the
president at no point of course
delegated to the special prosecutor the
exclusive right
to pass on the question of of executive
privilege or any other privilege
attorney and client privilege or any
other testimonial privilege
what we are merely saying is that we
have the clear right to test it in this
court
and this is on what we stand
well because of the passage of time if i
may i think i should get to
other discussions unless there are
questions on this particular point
passing to the merits uh we would say
that if there is any one principle of
law that marbury and madison versus
madison decides is that it is up to the
court to say what the law is
and almost to the point of redundance
but necessary because it was a landmark
decision
chief justice marshall reasoned we think
with clarity and emphasis that it is
emphatically the province and the duty
of the judicial department to say what
the law is
and this court of course through the
years
has uh reaffirmed
consistently applied that rule it's done
it in a number of cases and powell
versus mccormick
in the youngstown steel
seizure case
and doe versus macmillan
and
a footnote i think a very important one
appears
in that opinion
when mr justice white pointed out
that while an inquiry such as involved
in the present case
because it involves two coordinate
branches of government
must necessarily have
separation of power implications
the separation of powers doctrine has
not previously prevented this court from
reviewing the acts of congress
even when it is pointed out
the executive branch is also involved
now there are a number of cases that
speak to that
i think one of the cases that perhaps
went into greater detail and also points
out quite a distinguishing feature
is a gravel case whereas in the gravel
case the court did hold
that
it was appropriate to go into certain
matters
where privilege had been
exercised on the part of a senator on
behalf of his aide
there are
two things that i believe clearly help
us
in that decision and also other
decisions as far as the questions here
are involved one is
that
the speech or debate clause is in the
constitution
as is the journal clause is in the
constitution
it's written in there
and this is what was invoked
i don't find anything written in the
constitution
and nothing has been pointed that is a
writing in the constitution that relates
to the right of the exercise of
executive privilege on the part of the
president
another very important thing it's
pointed out in that case is that it did
involve an examination into wrongdoing
on the part of those
uh who were seeking to invoke the
privilege
and term eight executive privilege in
ancient
a bigger partnership the term executive
privilege an ancient one
it has been used over a period of time
how ancient uh
mr justice brennan i'm not in position
to say but certainly it has been one
that's been used over the years but it
is not one
and that i find any basis for in the
constitution
are you are you now arguing that there
is no such thing as executive property
no sir i didn't think so sir but i said
that no basis for it in the constitution
you think if anything it's a common law
privilege is that your point yes sir and
that it has been judicially recognized
and appropriately so in a number of
cases as we see it we do not think that
it is an appropriate one in this case
but we certainly do not for a moment
feel that it has any constitutional face
insurer against rose i i
think i thought we held that there is
a common law
privilege in the executives dealing at
the state level but that it is a
qualified privilege is that not so mr
chief justice that is exactly the point
this court has examined a number of
situations
and in some situations as i think was
pointed out earlier where military
secrets and such as that were involved
or national secrets of great importance
the court has taken a good close look
and has upheld
privilege
but when you say it has taken a good
close look without looking at the
evidence sometimes
taking a good close look at the
claim and the basis of the claim is that
what you mean that's what i mean but
doesn't this court said that it did have
constitutional overtones
[Applause]
said it had constitutional overtones
and i don't know in what case it may
have been used but uh
it proclaims i think
yes but it certainly has never placed it
in the constitution so far as i'm aware
of and president's council who have
carefully examined the authorities right
i was arguing about aluminum and
chemical corporation tests according to
claims
review
which judicially
tailored
yes sir
is it your view that
there are no
inferences to be derived from the
doctrine of separation of powers
are you saying this is purely an
evidentiary privilege
[Applause]
that uh the
privilege as
recognized judicially
may have been tied into the separate
separation of powers doctrine we don't
deny what we say is a separation of
powers doctrine
and the exercise in a calling for
executive privilege
has not been applied
in a number of instances involving both
congress and involving also the
executive despite the fact
that even in the congressional situation
speech and debate clause is there
what i am saying is that the separation
of powers doctrine has was pointed to
and the dove versus macmillan case has
not been permitted to stand in the way
of this court examining yet from the
standpoint of whether the executive
privilege should be
committed or not this is what he said in
reynolds the court ended up uh
treating the assession of privilege
there was an evidentiary privilege but
it did allude to the fact
that there was a constitutional question
and said the court wasn't reaching it uh
zarico
[Applause]
on the
the issue of executive privilege i
should point out here is a very narrow
one
and i think it's important that we bear
this in mind it doesn't involve a loss a
very large or broad uh
privileged rights
what it really narrows down to is
somewhat simple but very important issue
in the administration of criminal
justice and that is whether the
president
in a pending prosecution
can withhold material evidence from the
court
merely on his assertion that the
evidence involves confidential
communications and this is what really
gets down to
we know that sovereign prerogatives to
protect the confidentiality necessary to
carry out responsibilities in the fields
of international relations and national
defense are not here involved
and there's no claim of any state
secrets or that disclosure will have
dire effect on the nation or its people
actually uh
i think when we get to weighing
and
the non-disclosure as against disclosure
and i think when we begin to weigh the
balance of interest it would seem to me
that the balance clearly lies in favor
of a disclosure in a situation such as a
circumstance here
of course uh certainly would not be true
in case that the
fifth amendment was involved
but that's not present here not present
mr justice douglas and there is no
question but what the fifth amendment is
very plainly written out in the
constitution and is invoked as a clear
constitutional privilege
[Applause]
i think that it would be of help if i
may point out
to
the court
that
there is an excellent article that we
have alluded to in our briefs by
professor berger that appears in the
yale
law journal
which
discusses the aaron burr case at length
and also other cases that
have
been pointed to since the time of that
case
and if i may just say
very briefly that he summarizes the
situation by saying that the heart of
marshall's opinion
was therefore justly summarized by the
court of appeals in the nexus case in
the tapes case that we have talked about
[Applause]
the court was to show respect for the
president's reason
but the ultimate decision remained with
the court
and we're not suggesting for a moment
here that the matter of executive
privilege should not be looked into this
is not it's it deserves to be tested it
should be tested and we urge it to be
tested
but the ultimate decision is not one of
saying that it is absolute addressing
the constitution that doesn't entitle
anyone and doesn't authorize anyone
these name authorizes court to look into
it
because if the courts are the ultimate
interpreters of the constitution
and can
restrain congress to operate within
constitutional balance they certainly
shouldn't be empowered any less to
measure
presidential claims of constitutional
powers
i wanted briefly to make mention of the
question that has been raised by council
for the president that involves a
motion to expunge the finding of the
grand jury's
action that
the
president
is to be named as an unindicted
co-conspirator along with a number of
others when
the
pre-trial proceedings have gone into and
the bill of particulars is being filed
and i say that the grand jury is
finding painful as it is
i think on the part of the court
must be considered as being valid
and sufficient to show a prima facie
is sufficient to show prima facie that
the president was
involved in
the
proceedings in the course and in the
continuation
of the particular conspiracy that was
charged well is that the issue mr
jaworski or is the issue whether there
can be a collateral attack
that's also another issue
but i would merely want to point out
that i believe that this court would not
go into the grand jury's findings but
it's it's a private facial matter
and that this court would not go into it
for the purpose of determining
a matter of that kind
i thought we'd put that issue aside a
while ago
i just don't understand uh what the
relevance
is to this case
well
i have to agree with you neither do i
see what the relevance is of the matter
of saying that the uh there's another
argument advanced here and that is that
the president can't be indicted and i
don't know what the relevance of it is
in this case either very frankly because
it isn't before the court and yet the
argument is made and many uh phases of
brief should have voted i'm just
wondering
why you don't
aren't content with just arguing it is
irrelevant without
taking on the right
well this is why i skipped the argument
with respect to the matter of whether he
could be indicted or not but in as much
as this question had been raised and
briefed and emotion exists before the
court i have to agree that it isn't
relevant but it is a part of the case
that's the only reason i alluded to it
and i have no interest in spending much
time on it well except part of
part of the grounds on which you rest in
uh subpoenaing this material
is the fact that the president has
himself been named as a
co-conspirator an unindicted one and uh
that's true isn't it that's part at
least to the grounds upon you
which you rest in subpoenaing this
material
and uh the response to that is
the the president cannot
constitutionally be named as an
unindicted co-conspirator so to that
extent it is
it's in this case the questions in this
case
well i don't think it's a matter that
very frankly has any particular basis to
it because i don't see how
this court could be asked to substitute
its judgment for that of the grand jury
well that's something quite different
again whether or not there was
sufficient evidence for the grand jury
to justify the grand jury and naming the
president that's quite a different and
as
chief justice suggested a collateral
issue that's right
but uh the issue of whether or not the
president can constitutionally be named
by a grand jury uh as a co-conspirator
even though on an unindicted one
is at least tangentially before us
because that's
it's the fact that he has been named by
the grand jury that is part of the
grounds and part of the foundation upon
which you have based your subpoena
deuces taken
not only that i think that it has to
pinpoint it
in our view
immateriality because it does relate to
the question of
the
proof
that
we are seeking the relevance of the
proof that we are seeking
and this gets into of course a
discussion of matters that are sealed
and which i i discussed with the court
right but whether or not they had the
authority
they did
it is a fact that the grand jury did it
that's correct
and so it doesn't i don't see how we
have anything to do with whether they
had authority or not it's a fact
[Applause]
isn't that true that's
i think correct
now uh
i thought the heart of this case would
be there were the rights of defendants
and criminal trials
[Applause]
that
that is very much it may be exculpatory
and and freedom of all liability
i don't know but i well it certainly
isn't the case now and of course what
you have reference to also i'm sure mr
justice douglas is the bray and and
jenks the brave opinion maryland versus
bray and the jenks and this is a part of
the case however it happens not to be a
part of the appeal although it is a part
of the case but as far as our position
is concerned
it doesn't relate to that but certainly
it's true
that this material as we had pointed out
in our communications to the president
may well involve exculpatory matters and
we time it again pointed out we wanted
them not simply because we felt
that there were matters that needed to
be developed in connection with
prosecution but that they could well
contain exculpatory matters so the brady
question really lurks just in the
background does it not that is if you
get
information whatever you get
uh will be what you would uh concede is
available to any defendant that's right
who can make a show that's correct and
the question of whether or not the
defendants under the brady doctrine are
entitled
to subpoena
information and material that's not now
in your possession but is in the
possession of the president
uh was an issue that was left undecided
by the district court that's correct
for this court right
i believe with the permission of the
court unless there are further questions
i'll reserve the rest of the time for
the close
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
mr sinclair
mr chief justice and members of the
court
my learned brother has approached this
case
i think in a traditional point of view
namely this is an attempt by
a special prosecutor to obtain what he
thinks is desirable evidence and a
criminal prosecution that he has a
responsibility for
not once however have i heard him
mention
what i think is really
involved at least in significant part
and that is the co-pendency of
impeachment proceedings before the house
of representatives
and the realistic fusion that has taken
place with respect to these two
proceeds and the promise of continued
fusion as i understand my brother's
position
may i quote from a page
early i think sir they really are
first by way of factual background
this whole authority
was in the house
that's correct authority to try was in
the senate
right and the court shall not be used to
implement or aid that process which is
what is happening in this case
this case wouldn't be here on july the
8th just how is this done how is this
case implemented i would like to uh
review some of the facts for you in this
regard which i am the record
yes my brother has mentioned them to you
no but are they in the record not what
he's mentioning
yes yes sir well we're just an adjunct
of the house the tradition that this
case should be dismissed as in probably
granted
exactly right sir
not only that it makes the case
unjusticiable at least
now
[Music]
[Applause]
is that what you want no the case should
be dismissed sir
if we just misses it probably granted i
submit to the district court's opinion
which the judge would stand
and i i would retract what i said this
case should be dismissed
the case the case would be on appeal in
the court of appeals if we discuss
already
all right are you now talking about the
the
bypassing of the court of appeals
no sir i'm talking about the proceeding
before the district court through the
court of appeals to this court well but
if we dismiss this appeal as improvingly
granted it would go back to the court of
appeals
well as i say i think this case should
be dismissed period no really what you
mean is that you think that the order of
judges should have said they didn't set
aside that's right that's quite
different from dismissing the cases i
agree that's deciding on the merits yeah
that's right
that's what i'm trying to get across to
this court perhaps unartfully this case
should be disposed of be it by vacating
the order by below or not but in any
event it is improper in our view that
this case should be heard in the context
that is now being heard
we wouldn't be here on july the 8th
before a crowded courtroom
uh if it was not recognized generally
well it's a political question here
exactly the question in the district
court
and therefore it's a non-justiciable
issue in this and in the district court
what has happened in this case is did
you argue that to
the district judge
um i believe we argued the
non-justiciability argument yes sir i
know we did
but if you're your position is that the
issuance of a subpoena just taken is not
a judiciable
issue
in this context at this time sir
what has happened is this
as you know on february the 24th a grand
jury secretly named the president among
others as an unindicted co-conspirator
that fact was not made known on march
the first re an indictment was returned
against a number of the president's
chief aides
coincident with that and in an open
courtroom
the assistant prosecutor special
prosecutor handed up to the judge a bag
together with a sealed letter requesting
that this material be sent over to the
house of representatives
the president took no position regarding
that proposal
because he considered it to be probably
appropriate
under the belief that there was nothing
accusatory in that material judge sarika
himself reviewed the material found
nothing accusatory and said it would
therefore be quite appropriate
to send this material to the house of
representatives
not realizing and not knowing
that the special prosecutor had
previously obtained a secret charge
against the president and others
which was definitely accusatory
as i understand it was not
among the material that was conveyed to
the grand jury you know there seems to
be if i'm
at least that's what i understood mr
jaworski to tell us this morning
the material that was turned over was
before the grand jury
now just a moment
i understood mr jaworski to tell us this
morning very unambiguously and
explicitly
that the fact that the president was
named as an unindicted co-conspirator
was not conveyed to the grand jury
it was
the house of representatives to the
house of representatives no it was not
it was the material was sent to the
house of representatives in the belief
that it was non-accusatory in nature it
was simply a recital effect exactly and
that's what mr jaworski has represented
again to us this morning was the fact of
the matter but
mr jaworski had available to him unknown
to the judge and unknown to counsel for
the president a secret indictment naming
the president is a co-conspirator
the accusatory part followed later
now followed in what form by a newspaper
leak yes it wasn't sent from the court
over to the great over to the house
it didn't have to be all they had to do
was read the newspaper
it can be no question about it
and therefore i say this case has to be
viewed realistically in the context that
it is now being heard
i'm not sure
perhaps you can help me are you
suggesting that there was some duty on
the part of the
uh special prosecutor to just
disclose to the district judge
that
there was this secret indictment before
the judge passed on
whether the material should be sent to
the house
i think it would have been quite
appropriate because the judge's decision
was based on the proposition there was
nothing accusatory that under the
circumstances uh absolute fairness was
appropriate and
required and so far as the president was
concerned no one could argue that the
indictment as a co-conspirator naming as
a co-conspirator
does anything but impair
the president's position before the
house of representatives that should in
my judgment have been made known to the
judge i don't know what he would have
done under those circumstances
his his uh decision was based
solidly on the proposition there was
nothing accusatory
in the material
now
my brother says in his brief that this
material he now seeks
of course will be
available to the house committee
and will be used to determine whether or
not the president should be impeached so
this fusion is going to continue
and under the constitution as we view it
only the legislature has the right to
conduct impeachment
proceedings
the courts have been
from the history involved and from the
language of the provisions excluded from
that function
and yet the special prosecutor is
drawing this court into those
proceedings inevitably
and inexorably
no one could stand here and argue with
any candor that the decision of this
court would have no impact whatsoever
on the pending inquiry before the house
of representatives
concerning the impeachment of the
president
how far does your
point go
uh let's assume that uh
um
murder took place on the streets of
washington of which the president
happened to be one of the very few
eyewitnesses
and somebody was indicted for that
murder and the president was subpoenaed
as a witness would you say he cannot be
subpoenaed now because there's an
impeachment inquiry going on and the
courts absolutely have to stop dead in
their tracks of doing their ordinary
judicial business i would not say that i
don't think he could be necessarily
subpoenaed i don't think the president
is subject to the process of the court
unless he so determines he would give
evidence but the murderer
in this case you're saying that the
store the courts as i understand it have
to stop dead in their tracks from doing
their ordinary business
uh
in any matter involving uh even
tangentially the president of the united
states if as or when the uh a committee
of the house representatives is
investigating impeachment uh no justice
stuart i'm not the subject matter of
these two
matters
is the same subject matter well
here are should the president people
have been indicted six of whom remain
under indictment
uh
the trial is scheduled for next
september 9th right the prosecutor is
preparing for that trial he's trying to
under rule 17 of the
federal rules of criminal procedure to
deduce matters to be used in evidence at
that trial you say that cannot go
forward
uh because of some tangential effect or
you say a direct effect
upon some other matter okay going on in
the in another branch of the government
and how far it is i say it should not go
forward at this time at the very least
because the subject matter being
inquired of in in large measure before
the house committee is exactly the same
subject matter being
involved in this argument how do we know
namely should the president produce
tapes
one of these tapes involves the
impeachment procedure
what
in any of these tapes is involved in the
impeachment procedure well if your honor
please the house of representatives has
subpoenaed well i don't know one more
thing
in the case i assume you do no i don't
you don't know either well how do you
know that they subject to executive
privilege
well i do know that there's a
preliminary showing that they are
conversations between the president and
his close aides
regardless of what it is
regardless of what is it may involve uh
a number of subjects but does not the
special does not the special prosecutor
claim that the subject matter is the
same he claims that but he has no way of
showing it in fact he says it's only
probable or likely
he has no way of showing that they in
fact involve the subject of watergate
this claim is honored but this court
all would happen to be the evidence to
go to ted sirica
who would take it examine it and camera
house
i presume that so and
he would then it would be made available
the special prosecutor the special
prosecutor says that of course this
would then become part of the
impeachment proceedings and there we are
mr sanclear going back to this
murder witness situation if the
president any president uh witnessed an
automobile accident and was the sole
witness or a murderer as mr justice
stewart suggested you're not you're not
indicating that his testimony
his evidence would not be available to
the court but merely that he can't be
subpoenaed but might give it by
deposition as several presidents have
that is quite correct the testimony of
justices of this court has been given in
past times by
really as a matter of accommodation not
as a matter of assertion of the right of
one branch over another
but the point i want to make
justice potter is that the same subject
matter is is inexorably involved in both
proceedings now proceeding on at the
same time
and uh
you know the house of representatives
has not
well that's a a very good question i'd
like to answer the decisions that are
made in an impeachment proceeding
justice marshall are essentially
political decisions oh yeah i'm coming
in this case you said you'll give up 20
of them in this case yes we will
because they've already been made public
the tapes or transcriptions we are as
soon as a judge approves some method of
validating the accuracy of these tapes
they can have
you can have the tapes but you have to
understand a tape is a part of a reel
a reel may cover a dozen conversation
so there's a mechanical problem of
trying to validate or
be sure that this is correct but it's
only a mechanical problem once that's
solved subject to the judgment below his
approval they have the availability of
that indicates that you're willing to
release
be valuable to the watergate committee
in congress
we think so that's why we made them well
i thought you said you didn't want them
to have anything
this was merely an evidence a way of
getting stumped over to him but you
don't get himself
i say this i say the president should
decide as a political matter of what
should be made available to the house
that the court ought not to be drawn
into that decision
the house takes a different view
the house has subpoenaed something in
the neighborhood of 145 tables
and that's a political decision so the
house can get them the president can get
them and the only people i know can't
get them is pulling
the the president has not honored
any of the subpoenas other than the
first one issued by the house
so that there is a dispute in the house
now between the president
and the the committee on the judiciary
it's essentially a political dispute
it's a dispute that this court ought not
to be drawn into
and this result of the decision in this
case wouldn't inexorably result in being
brought me that we're drawn into it by
deciding this case how are we drawn into
the impeachment proceeding by deciding
this case the impact of this of a
decision in this case undeniably mr
justice brennan in my view well anyone
cannot have any it will not be
overlooked of this court as um
but i would think it would be an
inappropriate
uh thing to do at this time because
there is a different thing you've been
arguing we have absolutely no
authority
now
to decide
i will argue that in a moment but i'm
arguing now only that you should not
i'm arguing now sir only that you should
not
because it would involve this court
inexorably in a political process
which has been determined by the
constitution to be solely the function
of the legislative branch
and it
cannot be that in the impact of this the
court's decision in this matter which is
one of the principal matters now pending
before the house
would be overlooked it it would
certainly as a matter of realistic fact
have a significant impact but as i said
before we have
the beneficiaries here
are six
[Applause]
and what the president has may
free them completely
uh mr justice douglas we
if
it may
the brady issue we don't believe is
properly before the court it has not
been briefed by us nor by my brother was
not decided by the day and was not
decided by the district court i would
only say this that in the experience
that i've had in connection with cases
tried such as the stanz mitchell case in
new york the chapin case in washington
the erlickman case now going on there
has never been a claim that the
president has not made available
appropriate and adequate brady material
but i don't believe it's before this
court at this time what is before this
court is a prosecutor's demand for
evidence and i may i i direct my uh
remarks for a moment to that problem he
says that in effect we have no right to
be here
that we have delegated
the who
the when
and with what issues to him
we have delegated the who and the when
and pursuant to that he has indicted a
number of people
and he has indicted him at such time as
he thought appropriate
but even he contends we did not delegate
to him
what presidential conversations would be
used as evidence that was reserved
and he concedes that that is the fact
and that's what it's issue here not when
and who is to be indicted but what
presidential communications are going to
be used as evidence
and that's what the issue is in this
case mr sinclair uh
you left me in a little bit of
doubt about this mechanical problem i
think perhaps we diverted you from it
are you suggesting that on a given tape
which is a real type of thing having
an hour or more of material or maybe
several hours or two or three days two
or three days oh i see
that the first three hours might
be the material which has already been
transcribed and released
the next three or four hours might be a
conference with the joint chiefs of
staff or the chairman of the atomic
energy commission on
the program to give underdeveloped
nations
for example
aid for peaceful uses of atomic energy
matters totally irrelevant but
confidential is that your argument it's
my argument and the fact
for example
and you want some mechanism
set up so that
these things can be screened out
they have been screened out in the
transcripts
whatever has been published to the
public
we are quite prepared to verify the
accuracy of now in the course of those
transcripts there are first portions
left out have you at any time tendered
a or proffered a statement that
a particular tape from
18 minutes after 11 until three o'clock
that afternoon including the lunch hour
included a conference with the secretary
of state the secretary of defense and
someone else having to do with
totally unrelated matters has that kind
of a tender been made no we've simply
published the portion of that
conversation that did not relate to that
with the notation that a portion has
been left out
but no explanation of why it's left out
it was left out because it did not
involve presidential action as it
related to watergate or something to
that effect
we did not disclose the substance of
that left out material is there any
particular reason why the at least the
identity of the conferees
could not be
made
there might well be such a reason
uh my proffer to my brother has been
that we will
verify the accuracy of the printed
transcript
so this twelve hundred and forty odd
pages of
presidential conversations that are
available to the public and available to
him
will be usable
in the trial now this may well involve a
mechanism approved by the court
involving counsel for the defendants to
be satisfied so if they're satisfied
that the uh
copy is accurate but this all has to be
explicated out of a take out of a reel
of tape that may involve several days
conversation
but it's essentially a mechanical
problem but in the
tapes that they asked for in this
subpoena this is taken which is the only
thing before
has any effort been made to say what if
any part of that can be
other than the 20 that are already
published no effort has been made as yet
sir why not
because if your honor please we haven't
felt that it's been necessary to do so
because we firmly feel why well that the
president has every right to refuse to
produce this thing to disappear
as sufficient reason for you to try but
we moved to question ignored it didn't
no sir we didn't emotionally
well if your honor please we are
submitting the matter you're submitting
the matter to this court to this court
under a special appearance on behalf of
the president you're still leaving it up
to this court to decide it
well
yeah yes in the sense
what in what sense
in the sense that this court has an
obligation to determine the law
all right
the president also has an obligation to
carry out his constitutional force to
decide whether or not executive
privilege
is available in this case
well probably the question is even more
limited than that is is the executive
privilege which my brother concedes
absolute or is it only conditional i
said in this case can you make it any
narrower than that
no sir
well do you do you agree that that's
what before this court and you're
submitting it to this court for decision
which this is being submitted to this
court for its guidance and judgment with
respect to the law
the president on the other hand has his
obligations under the council are you
submitting it to this court for this
court's decision
as to what the law is yes
if of course we're not so you would not
be here i would not be here
now my brother says i have no
right to even challenge his right to be
here and i'd like to deal with that for
a moment this is as we point out in our
brief essentially
an executive department matter
whatever may have been the arrangements
between
the branches of the executive manner
with respect to evidentiary matters
and in fact there were no arrangements
regarding evidentiary matters it is not
the function of the court
to direct
or rule what evidence will be presented
to it
by the executive in the executive's duty
of prosecuting
if this was a united states attorney
this case wouldn't be here of course
it's here only because certain things
were delegated to the special prosecutor
but the special prosecutor was not
delegated the right to tell the
president what of his conversations are
going to be made available as evidence
that was specifically reserved and the
only thing that my brother can do is
argue about it and that's what he's
doing right here today
now therefore
why why wouldn't this case be here if
it's for a united states attorney i
think i agree with you but i'd like to
ask you
well the united states attorney would be
directed
by whom by the president
or the attorney general at the direction
of the president who directed the united
states attorney well by the attorney
general at the direction of the
president no no in the normal case the
president doesn't know anything about
mine run federal prosecutions that's
fair to say isn't it i think so but most
cases don't involve in fact in my run
cases the attorney general doesn't know
much about it
i think that's uh but let's just
the uh with all due respect right uh
so a united states attorney brings
prosecution
and uh
in the course of that prosecution he uh
before trial subpoenas uh under rule 17
17 of the federal rules criminal
procedure he
subpoenas material
in the custody of the president so what
happens
the president says to the attorney
general i'm not going to
produce this material no it's the united
states attorney subpoenaing it under
your hypothetical case that's right and
so what happened the president in my in
my view the president would instruct the
attorney general to instruct the united
states attorney to withdraw his motion
and the united states attorney says i'm
not going to do that because uh
you know united states attorney
well i'm making a little facetious
tonight no i'm being serious because i
think that united states attorney in all
respects would and should be removed
from that case the executive power of
the of the government is not vested in
the united states attorney it's vested
in one man and that man is the president
statute it's uh it's vested in the
law enforcement is vested in the
attorney general yes but that statute
which my brother cites in his brief
does not deprive nor could it deprive
the president of his constitutional
authority to be the chief law
enforcement officer he shall take care
to see the laws enforced the executive
power is vested in him in one man
and the attorney general is nothing but
a surrogate for
the president of the united st your
argument would be a
is a very good one as a matter of
political science and it would be a very
fine one as a matter of
constitutional and probably statutory
law except hasn't your client
dealt himself out of that argument by uh
by what's been done in the creation of
uh the special prosecutor perhaps as
you've just pointed out perhaps that
prosecutor is quite different from the
united states attorney right perhaps
with respect to everything except
the president did not delegate to the
special prosecutor the right to tell him
whether or not his confidential
communication should be made available
as evidence so that within the package
of executive power but normally
represented
excuse me
normally represented by the executive
department as to who shall be prosecuted
that's been delegated to this gentleman
he's exercised that power
when he's done that
with what evidence he's done that as
we'll deal with in a few moments but
not with that portion of the evidence
that's available that constitutes
presidential confidential communication
that's been specifically reserved
and the special prosecutor cannot and
even if the president did give him that
authority probably could not
it's a constitutional matter to delegate
that but in any event
he could not the right to order the
president to give up confidential
communication that was not delegated not
the unfettered right to get it but the
right to go to court and ask a court to
decide whether or not he's entitled to
it right and the president under no
circumstances gave up any of his
defenses no with respect to them you're
making those defenses
right now and even if we did agree
between us that we would best
this court was jurisdiction
simply because of the politics of the
situation
this court by
all
of its decisions would not accept the
vesting of such jerusalem no
why not because this court determines
its jurisdiction the parties can't agree
on that oh yes but
and if surely you're right as i say a a
lawsuit between us the secretary of
commerce for example suing the president
over a matter of executive policy we
both agree would be unthinkable and the
since these any cabinet officers the
creature of the president who appointed
him the answer would be you're fired
if you want to if it goes that far if it
goes that far that's right but aren't we
here met both
factually and i suggest legally with
quite a different situation i think not
in the terms of separation of powers if
i may my brother's point of view is he
views himself as the united states as
distinguished from a member of the
executive branch and in his brief he
invokes the united states as really a
fourth entity well constitutionally a
special prosecutor with the powers that
my brother suggests he has is a
constitutional anomaly we have only
three branches not three and a third or
three and a half or four
there's only one executive branch and
the executive power is vested in a
president now if for political reasons
the president wants to dole out some of
those powers
he may so do and has done in this case
but he cannot vest
jurisdiction on a court
that otherwise the court would not have
nor should the court accept
jurisdiction but hasn't uh your client
also inhibited himself
from
the ultimate
sanction that you uh suggested he could
impose with respect to your hypothetical
united states attorney i.e the
sanction of
dismissing the special prosecutor that
is a matter of law regulations that have
the force of law that is correct and he
has not been dismissed
and until or unless he is
nor is he like we have a case or
controversy of a very real kind
the point is if i may make the only
issue here is whether the president gave
up his right
to protect the confidentiality of his
conversations certainly no claim is made
that he did you're a living testimony of
the fact that he did not give up his
rights my brother conceived
the very fact the very fact that the
delegation to mr jawarski
gave him the right to contest the
president's claim of privilege
presupposed that the president had a
right
to assert the privilege
not the right to assert it necessarily
with complete finality
that's the that's what we're really
arguing about here today isn't it no if
we get beyond the subject matter
situation now if this were
all the nixon against sarika case
where he didn't have what i think is
disposed a dispositive problem in this
case namely the lack of jurisdiction in
the judicial branch to involve to
determine this
intra-executive branch if we had a grand
jury subpoena
as was true in the nixon against eureka
case then you have intra branch and the
court would have a better standing in
its responsibility to see the grand
juries which are under its jurisdiction
uh to have such evidence as they thought
appropriate but we're well beyond that
stage 17c requires a great
uh
a much more restricted
form of evidence it's got to be relevant
and admissible it's nothing like a grand
jury subpoena mr singh therapist with
reference to your point about whether
there are three branches or three in
some fraction
is not the controller general or
something of
an autonomous
fractional
more than
a third branch figure
well i don't think that the controller
general represents uh if your honor
please that the the basic constitutional
structure has been changed
it may be that he has received executive
and he may have legislative functions he
may proceed with reference to the
executive branch and i would assume with
reference to expenditures of the
legislative branch
and uh without without consulting either
one of them is that i understand it it's
he is created by a legislator it's very
much like a semi-independent agency
in one aspect he's an agent of the
legislature in the other aspect he's an
agent of the executive but we don't have
any more than legislative judicial and
executive branches mr jawarski as i
understand it is
is claiming that he's
somewhat like not necessarily precisely
like but somewhat like the controller
general
that he may make decisions and that
congress cannot recall him short of the
i believe a 15-year term for the
comptroller general
and the president to no president can
fire the controller general
and i suppose
the court could not fire
well i'm sure the court couldn't i'm not
too clear about the president under the
myers case uh i really haven't thought
that much of it
uh it could be that he could be fired
but i think that's really somewhat
beside the point because this issue
really turns on
an admission that as to the element of
the of the executive power here involved
namely presidential conversations they
weren't delegated
so whatever else may have been delegated
those were not
and this court has no jurisdiction to
resolve a dispute as to whether or not
they should be given up
because that would involve this court in
the prosecution of the case in the
judicial court decide what's necessary
for trial of a criminal case
it can sir with respect to third parties
but it should not involve itself with
the executive function of prosecuting
the case
my only question was that this is a
payment business teacum
that was issued by a judge
right yes sir
slightly judicial points
entirely judicial
and that's what before us and that we
moved to quash because we was that's
what before us
the denial of our of uh our emotions of
course is one of the issues before us
that's right the only thing before us is
the weather not the subpoena should
issue
i guess it's about the same thing as
whether or not it should be quashed and
i think that amounts to the same thing
so that's that's not political
well it is not in the context of the
proceedings here but in the context of
what is in fact involved in this case it
is i suggest political in the sense that
this information being sought admittedly
will become available then to the house
what we mean political well i don't see
where the house has got anything to do
with the point that i'm talking about
she said this is political and not
judicial
[Applause]
and i submit it could be judicial
because it involves the issue of
subpoena
well the question is is it a proper
issue of a subpoena that's right judges
make mistakes as as do lawyers and
maybe even presidents for all i know but
the point i want to make with you sir is
that this is an executive function an
executive decision one not delegated
well the executive function is i
understand the discussion
as to whether you should voluntarily
turn them over to the special prosecutor
we have passed that stage
we are now at the stage where the
prosecutor
has asked the court
to assist him
and the court has assisted him
does that not take it a step beyond pure
political
or executive
we submit the court improperly assisted
him that the court has no right to
determine what the executive will offer
in evidence
and this is the function of the
president no one has contended that the
president has given up his executive
responsibilities under the constitution
and certainly the prosecution of
criminal cases is an executive function
and that's absolute
now you argue an absolute
privilege
that's absolutely executive even though
every day or so you hit your other one
no we don't turn them loose every day
but we have turned a number loose in the
president's discretion in which he
thought was the appropriate thing to do
and that's his determination the
governance we suggest you get ready to
turn 20 more tapes for you
now these would be repetitious your
honor what already been made public
well i thought you said you preached you
would turn 20 loot well those are 20 uh
those would be the tapes of 20
conversations already made public you
release those trades
we'll provide a means whereby their
accuracy can be verified to release a
whole reel of tape involving a number of
conversations poses a mechanical problem
you're still saying the absolute
privilege to decide what
shall be released and what shall not be
released is vested in one person
and nobody can question it
in so far as it relates to the
presidential conversations that is
correct sir but you're now dealing
that's another issue mr sinclair with
the jurisdictional question and as i
further understand it that
argument of yours
at least i got from the brief involves
at least two separate concepts and maybe
three
uh one is that this is an intra branch
dispute and that
argument would be equally valid under
your the analogy you use in your brief
if this were a dispute between let's say
two committees in one of the houses of
the congress
and one committee sued the other for
jurisdiction of a particular matter you
suggest and probably quite correctly
that that would not be
a matter for the judiciary to determine
that's one argument that this is purely
an intra executive branch
controversy
as it would be
between two congressional committees
this is intron
article two branch
the hypothetical case would be intra
article one branch
that's one argument and then you have
quite a separate argument it seems to me
i.e that the
president constitutionally is the chief
prosecutor since he is the executive
and that it's not for the courts to
decide what a prosecutor
shall use in prosecuting a criminal case
now isn't that aren't those two separate
arguments you'd make both of them under
this rubric that's correct
uh i don't know how separate they are
but i certainly told they're quite
separate but they're making both of them
and if they're separate fine now it's
respectful the second argument would
have no relevance at all to the to your
analogy of the of the legislative branch
well i i don't want to mislead the court
into thinking that i believe mr jaworski
has no right
to determine any evidence that he can
use but ultimately you tell us that it's
the constitutionally the
president as chief executive and
therefore as constitutionally the chief
prosecutor whatever the statutes might
provide has unrestricted
uh discretion to determine what evidence
he will or will not use and prosecuting
a case that is correct which is quite a
different concept from the other concept
you make them both under the same rubric
as i say but i seems to me they're quite
separate arguments
uh and i and i think they're well
founded in the world
or you wouldn't make them
now i'd like to move if i may to
briefly uh
the suggestion that the issue here is
non-justiciable
on the grounds other than i've already
mentioned
namely the context in which this case
unfortunately now finds itself it seems
to us briefly that the case is
non-justiciable for
somewhat more technical reasons first
[Music]
this is an issue where
someone has to exercise some discretion
there are no real bounds or standards by
which that discretion should be
exercised
and by
traditional standards of this court
where that exists then this court ought
not to take the case
sexually
secondly it seems to me there is a
textual
constitutional grant if we assume
that the grant of executive power
includes the means by which that can be
effectively exercised
second ground
third of course there is the political
involvement which i have suggested
therefore i suggest uh quite
quite uh briefly
that even even if there is
subject matter jurisdiction
the case is non-justiciable for these
additional
reasons
the standards of baker and carr and
powell are not applicable here there's
no individuals rights who are being
protected against
the onslaught of government
the president is not here as an
individual he's here as the
constitutional officer
in whom the executive power is vested
there is no uh
philosophy that would support a finding
of justiciability on the grounds that
were
strengthening the
democratic process as was true in powell
and
also to a greater extent in baker and
carr
if anything a decision in this case
against the president
would tend to diminish
the democratic process this president
was elected on the theory that he would
have all the powers duties and
responsibilities of any other president
and if it's determined that he doesn't
there is a certain amount of diminution
of the
political
aspect of the case and so far as the
constituents who voted for him are
concerned
this president ought not to have any
less
powers than any other president ought to
have
and one of the
necessary results as i view it in my
brother's argument is
that because of the circumstances of
this case richard nixon is let's say an
85 percent president
not a 100 president and that can't be
constitutionally
the framers of the constitution had in
mind a strong presidency
as we know they considered a number of
alternatives maybe
a presidency consisting of three members
all of those suggestions were discarded
and a strong presidency
was decided upon may i say to the
distinct advantage of this country as
history has developed
now by reason of an action of a grand
jury
the special prosecutor suggests that
this president has something less than
any other president would have
i would only call your attention to the
action of the framers and constitutional
convention when the issue was raised as
to whether or not a president who was
under impeachment should be suspended
during the pendency of the impeachment
proceedings the decision was definitely
he should not
because the framers
envisioned a strong
active
president even in the course of
impeachment proceedings they did not
want this country to be led by someone
who didn't have those full powers even
if he were then under impeachment
and indeed this president continues to
function as president as he should
even though there are impeachment
inquiries
underway
mr sinclair if i may interrupt you again
is this
is what you're telling us now directed
to your point
that this is a
non-justice non-justice evil political
question or is it directed to your point
that the
the executive privilege is absolute and
that the determination of it is to me i
think it it involves both
uh it's non-justiciable if i may because
it does involve
the court in a political matter now mere
fact that politics is involved of course
has not prevented the court from taking
action in appropriate cases
where individual rights are involved or
where
the franchise of voters
could be strengthened by the decision in
the court i'm suggesting in this case
the converse is true therefore
the justification between
baker and carr and in
powell case is not available or not
applicable here furthermore however
the argument still in my view has forced
with respect to the consequences of the
grand jury action
in naming him as a co-conspirator which
we suggest they were
not qualified to do
the president is not above the law by
any means
but law as to the president
has to be applied in a constitutional
way which is different than anyone else
namely we suggest
that he can only be impeached
while in office
and cannot be indicted until such time
as he no longer
is in office well let's assume we accept
that
proposition what follows from it well
then the naming of the president by a
grand jury as a co-conspirator if that
has the effect of diminishing
the president's rights it's a pro tanto
if i may say
uh impeachment i should think you could
run the argument the other way saying
that since
the president cannot be indicted then
all that can happen to him is that he be
can be named as a
unindicted co-conspirator
that could be said but by the naming of
an unindicted co-conspirator we suggest
is an intrusion by the grand jury on a
function that is solely legislative and
not judicial
well the president could be a president
could be sued could lead or back taxes
or
penalties or whatnot
well then questions of immunity
i think individually he could be speaks
of persons any person
that's correct i think the president
could be sued for back taxes uh in his
individual capacity
but in terms of his power to uh affect
the responsibilities of his office to
protect the presidency from unwarranted
intrusions into the confidentiality of
his communications that's not a personal
matter
it may be in one of these defendants
might be completely exonerated
from something in one of those states
as i've suggested that if that defendant
will satisfy a court that there is such
a tape and will identify or even come
close to it and and persuade a court
that that would exonerate them or
there's reason to believe it might i
don't believe we'll have a question
but that's not what my brother here is
asking for
he's asking for a set number of tapes
not for brady purposes although he
throws that in but he really wants them
he says
for prosecution
and i'd like to review with the court
the question of the necessity shown for
this because even on his theory
of a qualified privilege
there has to be a showing of some
necessity
now we should understand i'm sure the
court knows that all of these
individuals here involved
have testified before the senate select
committee with exception i believe of mr
colson who now has pled guilty under a
plea bargain where he's agreed to
cooperate so the special prosecutor has
the full benefit of his testimony
they have testified on one or more
occasions before a grand jury
in addition the president has furnished
to the special prosecutor the
transcripts and tapes of the critical
conversations involved in this alleged
conspiracy and i might review those very
briefly with you
mr dean in his ten senate committee
testimony suggested that on september
the 15th the president acknowledged
uh knowledge of a cover-up
he changed that later to
testimony he believed that was so or was
an inference but in that event the
president furnished that portion of that
tape of the conversation with mr dean
mr dean also testified that on march 13
1973
he discussed the cover-up of the
president and efforts to blackmail the
president by one of the defendants who
broke into the democratic national
headquarters
later it developed that was mistaken
that it was actually on march the 21st
and the grand jury indictment proceeds
on the theory of march the 21st
the tape of the conversation on march
the 13th was furnished
all of the conversations between the
principles being two in number on march
the 21st were furnished
the conversation between the individuals
and the president on the next day in the
afternoon march the 22nd was furnished
and a large number of additional
conversations were furnished
now if reynolds means anything and
reynolds in addition to the kaiser
aluminum case noted a constitutional
question
as i think uh
one of the learning justices suggested
one of the reasons
for not
facing that issue in that case was it
was not necessary because
in the case there was a crash of a
bomber
that was on a secret mission
and the court said that the
parties had the testimony of the
witnesses the survivors and other
testimony so it wasn't necessary
to get to the constitutional question i
suggest that that's true here it's
difficult for me to conceive a
prosecutor who has more evidence
than this prosecutor has
he has the full benefit of a senate
select committee investigation which
staff had 50 odd lawyers existed for a
year
he has the benefit of his own
investigation
of a grand jury that sat for 19 months
with an investigative staff of similar
proportions
he simply says i need this because
i want to present all of the evidence in
the case he does not say
you suggest then that even if he could
the prosecutor could get this from a
normal
third-party witness he can't get it from
the president
because of executive privilege there
must be a further showing beyond
the relevance showing of 17c well as we
point out in our brief a tape of a
conversation is very wrong the answer is
yes
there is a further showing necessary
that's right does he really need this
what does he say he needs it for
but he says how does a district court go
about deciding a question like that
in advance of trial without unless the
prosecutor
lays out his entire evidence and says
it's my judgment that this is evidence
without this evidence i might lose the
cake he doesn't say that he made a
showing to the court below
the showing is available to you but you
would suggest that he would have to do
that he has the burden he has the burden
under reynolds under kaiser aluminum and
so forth to show that he needs it and
what does he say he needed for
he doesn't say he needs it to obtain
convictions i'm gonna say that well i've
got you interrupted i want to make ask
you something else
and it's related to this so
no matter how absolute uh
the executive privileges that you claim
on behalf of the president
i assume you're talking about
conversations to which the privilege
would apply
now is it we have to make such a showing
and i say that's our only burden uh you
wouldn't suggest that every conversation
the president has while he's in office
would be subject to executive privilege
no it has to be a confidential
communication well it has to be in the
course of his duties as president
but it's uh carrying out his duties as
president
uh as an art as as
under the constitution yes sir now
i don't suppose if he was talking with
one of his aides uh
uh mr holden mr ehrlich went about an
investment of his out in california or
somewhat some other place or a tennis
game or whatever yeah so you wouldn't
have suggested that my brother doesn't
suggest that's what he wants either well
how about conversations about a campaign
about the next campaign
now that's hard that gets a little close
a little closer very very close
as a political office too very close to
uh executing the laws of the united
states as if running a political
campaign
i don't think it's very close no and so
conversations about that something
matter my brother isn't seeking any such
conversation well i know but shouldn't
you
shouldn't the president
have to say at least even if
the privilege is as absolute as you say
it is
shouldn't he at least have to say
i
i believe or assert that the executive
privilege applies to this state because
this conversation is in the for the
course of the performance of his duties
as president
well as i as i read some of you haven't
done that either have you
we we have not done that we've simply
responded to an assertion that these all
relate to watergate assuming that to be
the fact would you automatically say
every conversation about watergate is in
the course of the performance of the
duties of the president of the united
states i would think it would be yes sir
why is that
because he had has the duty a to enforce
the laws that is to prosecute these
cases and b
he had to take care to see the laws
enforced that is to investigate
and much of this material does relate to
the investigation as twelve hundred and
some
pages of the public transcript fully
discloses but i would be ready to
concede and i don't think it's a
difficult problem between us that the
president should show
that these
uh circumstances are appropriate for the
claim of such a privilege and i think
such language uh appears in mink and
perhaps even in reynolds and in
kaiser aluminum simply it has to be a
confidential communication first of all
and how about uh did you could you
concede or do what is your view of the
privilege with respect to
whether it reaches uh factual assertions
in a conversation
the difference that was made in the mink
case and in others with respect to uh
opinions and judgments well as uh
as distinguished from the fact of course
mink i believe was a
statutory statutory case well that was
one of the exceptions so what is your
view uh uh would you say that
if a conversation is merely a recitation
of fact
it is still covered by executive
privilege yes it is if it's confidential
and it's between the president
and some adviser with respect to him
because otherwise that hasn't got much
to do with the decision-making process
just pure cold facts
it might well have to do with the
decision-making process is the facts are
such as were developed in the course of
an investigation with regard to the
existence
of a
obstruction of justice charge much of
which the president was involved in
but the fact against opinion decisions
really relate to another situation as i
suggest on the
uh
the statute but
the kind of the conversation that the
president has with his advisers we
suggest
is absolutely privileged it's a
discretionary matter
that he has to exercise and what he's
going to release and not release and
since marbury and madison
mississippi and johnson
it's been clear that the courts will not
direct the president
to exercise his discretion in any manner
this is not to say the courts won't
strike down as in sawyer excessive
action on the part of the president
or excessive action on the part of the
legislature that has happened a number
of times but it's a far different thing
to suggest that the court should
undertake to direct the president to
exercise his discretion in a certain
manner
it's not a ministerial duty by any means
it's a matter of discretion there's some
things he feels he probably should under
the circumstances make available and
others he shouldn't
the
discussion in that particular
one here
involves the relevancy of
materials to a criminal trial
and that normally has been a part of the
judicial power
under article three not the executive
uh i'd like to discuss very briefly
gravel if i may for example i think this
raises a very important question
there is of course an explicit speech
and debate
immunity provided in the constitution as
our brief indicates the reason for this
is quite clear is to protect the
legislature from
uh unwarranted invasion from the
executive perhaps even the judicial
does not mean that the executive is not
entitled to substantially the same thing
by implication
and at least in the civil field as we've
pointed out
the courts have worked out by
implication as a necessary ingredient to
the function of the the duties of the
executive and absolute immunity from
civil liability
for actions taken within the sphere of
the official
swallowing and violence i guess is the
leading case
cited
bar mateo in other cases
if such a matter can be worked out with
respect to the executive
on civil matters we suggest there is no
reason why
and in fact the court should spell out a
similar exemption in criminal matters
especially as they relate to the
president himself because while i said
the president is not above the law
the law can only be made applicable to
him in a certain way while he is in
office
now
if a junior congressman
can commit a crime on the floor of the
house as apparently as possible
under gravel and johnson
is it to be said that the president
united states has less
immunity than a junior congressman i
think not
so that i suggest to you
the common sense and
proper construction of the constitution
implying within the exact grant of
executive power all of those necessary
ingredients to make it work to be
effective which would include immunity
and criminal immunity
the present we suggest cannot be
indicted
can't even be named as a co-conspirator
because that's an assumption
of a legislative function under the
constitution
and therefore we suggest
that even if this is criminal
the president is immune from the
ordinary criminal process he's not
immune from process but that process
that's available to the president
is a process of impeachment which does
not include the function of the
judiciary branch
and therefore we say
that if under gravel the congressman
is entitled to immunity even from
criminal conduct for actions taken
within the legislative fear of his
sphere of misconduct
then it be very hard to support a
proposition
that the president as the chief
executive of the country is entitled to
less
except
they didn't put him in the constitution
right and the reason they didn't sir was
it was not found to be necessary they
didn't put civil immunity in the
constitution either for the executive
branch and this court has found of
course that there is such an immunity
i'm sorry sir
it was the speech and debate clause case
and it it even for bad as i understand
the gravel case
grand jury inquiry into motivations and
actions of the senator and his aide
because the constitution said stuff
right and i suggest the constitution by
clear implication provides the same not
only for the executive but for the
judicial as well but certainly for the
executive and if we can't find it in the
constitution whatever you are
well i would suggest you should find it
in the constitution it need not be
explicit it can well be implied the
question is if we can't find it what
happens to your argument
if you cannot find it
then if your honor please that portion
of the argument is lost as far as this
court's concerned i guess don't you
you haven't lost your other point which
says this court can
set up the same kind of privilege
they've set up another one that's
correct
and we're suggesting that it should in
this case
not necessarily because
a great deal is now left to be gained by
expunging the grand jury action my
brother is right the damage has been
done
and i we think quite improperly so
we think the tactics involved with the
prosecutor in seeking to
make enlarging the
scope of admissible testimony is hardly
worth what has been done here but it's
been done but seems to me history
would be served by a granting
of the relief we have prayed for below
namely to expunge this secondly it seems
to me the american people would feel
better about the fairness of the issues
now pending before the house if this act
which we say was improper and illegal
were expunged
but insofar as the mechanisms of this
case are concerned it destroys or
removes a basis upon which they contend
they are entitled to these documents i'd
like to address that for a moment we've
been asked many times to do that in
other cases with respect to grand juries
up today i don't think we've ever come
near anywhere near to it and up today
you've never had a president united
states named as a co-conspirator either
sir that's very true
and the president united states
i don't mean to be facetious about it
but the president united states we
suggest can be proceeded against only by
impeachment while in office
and his powers are unabated until such
time as he leaves that office
now with respect to this suggestion that
a grand jury finding his prima facie
evidence of course never been decided
either no
this case is unusual in many respects
this suggestion that a grand jury
finding is prima facie evidence and
therefore
the president has lost whatever
privilege he otherwise would have had
just it doesn't isn't borne out by the
either the facts or the
legal issues and principles involved a
grand jury finding is not prima facie
evidence
even if it's mentioned in an opening
argument in a criminal trial there's a
grave risk of a mistrial
the cases cited by my brother
particularly the clark case
are clearly cases which require a
showing in court or in clark is showing
to the judge
that there was prima facie evidence of
wrongdoing you may recall that's a case
involving an investigation into
a juror as to whether or not the juror
had performed
properly and the juror it had been shown
had testified falsely in the
qualifications that she had never had
any uh business relations with one of
the parties when in fact she had the
court said well there's a finding of
wrongdoing and based on that now i will
look into the jurors deliberations to
see what she did
but justice cardozo made it very clear
that if he hadn't been able to make a
prima facie showing of wrongdoing by
evidence before him there would have
been no cause for letting in the light
as he put it
and the ewing case and other cases which
are relied on by my brothers are all
cases where there was a prima facie
showing in a courtroom
now a grand jury charge is not primation
first place it's only accusatory it's
not even admissible in nor can it be
referred to in a trial
secondly it is it can well involve
incompetent evidence as this course
recently decided
and it's totally inappropriate to
suggest that a president who otherwise
would have a very valuable privilege and
i think i should emphasize the value of
this privilege
because it is a valuable privilege all
you have to do is read justice reid's
decision in kaiser aluminum and he
spells it out quite clearly the
importance and value of this privilege
to simply say to have a grand jury make
a charge that destroys that privilege
is an argument that i don't think can be
sustained mr sinclair you have not
mentioned in your argument
a few moments ago on the question
of the absence of any provision for
immunity for
judges
or the presidents
the government mentioned the
holding of this court in pearson against
ray where as i recall it the
the court
assumed with a sentence or two that
there was absolute privilege
for the judiciary but that the
privileges of the
executive in that case
policemen
was
qualified uh the court had no difficulty
in concluding that uh
it
did not require an express
constitutional provision to
to spell out uh an
privilege for judges
these were state judges in that case of
course well uh if you're of your honor
please uh i don't believe that simply
because the constitution
does not explicitly state the immunity
as it does in the speech and debate
clause should this court hold it does
not exist in criminal matters
i would like to make one point with the
court however
because i'm sure the point will be
raised concerning justice kerner for
example there's a distinct difference as
we point out in our reply brief as we
view it
between a president of the united states
a single individual in whom the entire
executive function is vested
a president serves seven days a week 24
hours a day
and only he
or those under him performing his
function
can exercise the executive function of
our government
now if a congressman or a senator or
even if a judge or a vice president or a
vice president
is removed from his duties
matters go on
but a president
doesn't have
that opportunity to take a vacation it's
vested in one individual and
deliberately so
this is pretty far afield from the
basic question here which is the
testimonial privilege
we say it's a con
not prosecutorial immunity but for
testimonial privilege is what we're
dealing with here that's correct i think
so
uh i would i want to make the point with
you that we think that the privilege
we're arguing for is both common law
and constant understanding it's
constitutional because it's inherent
in the executive power i understand
you're right okay and it's common
doesn't matter whether or not they can
a judge can be prosecuted criminally or
it's it's
it has to do with nothing to do with
testimonial privilege does it well my
brothers seem to think it does because
they say because
of the implications of criminality here
the president has lost something he
otherwise would not have had i
understand
since i've already interrupted you may i
please derail upon your good nature a
little more mr saint claire to ask you
uh whether
it is your claim that any of these uh
materials
have to do with what have sometimes been
called matters of state i.e
matters of international relations or
national defense uh mr jaworski assured
us
that they did not involve matters of
state but
i would like to hear what you have to
say about that because as you well know
both the commentators and court
decisions have
uh made it iconic dichotomy between uh
the privilege that exists with respect
to ordinary general confidentiality on
the one hand of the executive and
matters of state on the other to which a
higher privilege has sometimes been
thought to be accorded
well i think if a higher privilege has
been recorded it should not but in any
event the privilege of confidentiality
is not unimportant however let me let me
direct myself to your
to
your question the answer your question
is
no one knows
but you you won't know until you listen
to these tapes as to what subjects are
discussed
my brother can only state that it's
probable they relate at least in part to
whatever he says waterproof
or it's likely that it might and i've
had the experience for example
where circumstances were such that the
house committee felt
that it was likely that a conversation
took place between
the attorney general mr mitchell and the
president regarding
plans for surveillance of the democratic
party
when you looked at the conversation it
wasn't there at all
but in this case so i have no way of
knowing nor does the prosecutor know
what additional matters may be
interwoven into these conversations one
thing is certain believing mr sinclair
an understanding clear that in this case
to date
uh no representation has been made by
affidavit or professional representation
or otherwise that any of these materials
have to do with national defense or
international relations
no and no uh representation could be
made to the contrary either and that
would be there for a matter to be uh
under the existing order now under
review of judge sirika that would be
submitted to him
uh later
in camera if this court if this court
finds i say under his existing order yes
that's right right and the president
presumably uh
if he were to comply with that order
would make such a representation in an
appropriate case
but the fundamental point is
that we believe the reason stated
that the president's right to
confidential advice is important
and it's actually fundamental to the
proper functioning of his government
and in many instances i suggest is even
more important
in military matters and matters of state
so to speak
because no matter what the conversation
is of course it's the thought that
it might become public
that involves then this chilling effect
that we've made reference to in our
brief under the first amendment but as a
practical matter
and i can see it myself
the communications uh are not
free and open because
who is to say that it won't be called
before a grand jury
and most everyone in the white house has
been to call before a grand jury
sometimes several times
the fbi has interviewed every secretary
that had any knowledge of any aspect of
this case
this prosecutor has a plethora of
information
he says he wants to try this case with
all the evidence so he knows better than
that nobody tries any case with all the
evidence you'll be buried in minutia
you select the evidence that you think
most appropriate to your case
you don't try it with all the evidence
and this special prosecutor has
mountains who is going to determine how
much
evidence of prosecuting needs only the
prosecutor that's correct that's correct
not the court
and if that if that uh if that evidence
constitutes
presidential confidential communications
then i suggest if your honor please the
president determines that case has been
lost because the prosecutor had too much
of it well i suggest that's probably the
fact here
so when my brother says i don't need
this evidence to win these cases in my
opinion but i need them so i can present
all the evidence
i've been trying cases long enough to
know and so is he
that's not what he's really after yeah
i've tried to but same thing i was just
i was just wondering
where do you see the burden here
is on the
prosecution the burden on the under 17c
is clearly on the prosecution and the
burden is clearly on the prosecution on
every other aspect
now how much is enough for our phrase
you've been kicking around prime of
facing
well i suggest whatever was considered
by this court in reynolds to be enough
is more than enough in this case we have
the testimony of every individual
involved a number of them have pled
guilty dean has pled guilty colson has
pled guilty
combat is plague guilty et cetera et
cetera all under plea bargains where
they are under obligation to fully
cooperate this prosecutor is not nor
does he say at any point
that he needs this information to
prosecute successfully these cases
just to pinpoint another issue let's
assume for the moment that we didn't
agree with you on your test of privilege
and let's just assume that the only
issue that was left in the case
was the 17c issue
now
then the president wins in my view well
because because the prosecutor cannot
show that the evidence he seeks is
relevant
and admissible
because of the nature of the
circumstance he doesn't know what's in
there well uh i suppose there are two
parts of the question one how much of a
showing does he have to make as to
what's on what might be on the tape and
secondly if that
matter that he claims is on the tape is
on the tape is that
relevant and admissible
uh under 17c we'd have to know what the
matter was
what the issues in the case were but
under bowman and ioza
it's not enough to show that it probably
is or might be or is likely to be it
must be shown to be relevant and must be
shown to be admissible
that's why it's not a third party uh mr
secretary uh
you can't put an impossible task on
someone who wants a subpoena against a
third against a third-party witness
or against anybody else as to showing
what is precisely on
in some documents i would like to
support
well uh
if you want to utilize the 17c then i
suggest that's what you have to do he's
never listed he's never listened to the
tapes he uh doesn't know precisely
what's on them
you would say that he could never
subpoena a tape unless he had already
gotten it as a prosecutor that's right
as a grand jury that's another matter if
he had brought
southeast under a grand jury subpoena
we would then be directly faced with
nixon against sarika which we happen to
think was improperly and
incorrectly decided
but under 17c we're dealing with a
prosecutor's subpoena
the evidence of the decided cases make
it quite clear there must be a specific
showing
of relevance and admissibility now if he
can't do it because of the nature it
doesn't matter
that's that's his problem not mine
the cases you're talking about are cases
where uh where a defendant sought
discovery of evidence from the uh or or
sought
material in a prosecutor's fire most of
those cases are but there is at least
one case i think it's grossman that says
the rules are equally applicable to the
prosecution
decided one of the footnotes in our
breed but a 17c
subpoena
is
conceptually a subpoena for known
information
conceptually if the prosecutor is
looking for things he should utilize a
grand jury subpoena
in that case i think in bowman they they
wanted the
prosecutor to produce each document he
was going to use
in the presentation of his case that's
specific
it's obviously relevant
and admissible so uh once he gets
through with the grand jury okay he
shouldn't be using a subpoena to develop
his case that's correct
and certainly not into these i think
that's the practice and the
i think it is the practice i think that
the grand jury practice is
is far uh
far greater than perhaps the
constitution has envisioned it's really
used today frankly
as a effective
discovery tool
now i get back to
what seems rather fundamental to me
let us assume that it had been
established
that the conversations
we're talking about here today
did involve a criminal conspiracy
would you still be a setting an absolute
privilege
yes quite clearly
under the analogy was preval that i made
right and as i understand it
the public interest behind that
privilege
is the preservation of canada
in discussions between the president and
his closest age quite clearly so the
simple reason sir may i follow i'm sorry
what public interest is there in
preserving secrecy with respect to a
criminal conspiracy
the answer sir is a criminal conspiracy
is criminal only after it's proven to be
criminal
and we're not at that point yet
my uh question was based on the
assumption that it had been established
that the conversations did relate
to a criminal conspiracy that is the
case has been tried and defended
could have been established in various
ways as you've just said a number of
people have already confessed and these
people
were participants in some of these
conversations but the fact that one
defendant confessed does not make the
other defendant guilty of
course but anyway your answer is that
you would still first of all the answer
is yes even if it is criminal but more
importantly it is yes because
criminality is something that is not
necessarily determined at the time that
you might must resolve the issue
and that you should not destroy the
privilege in the anticipation of a later
finding of criminality which may never
come to pass
[Applause]
it is quite conceivable that a number of
these defendants will be found innocent
and in fact in theory they are innocent
right now
what is the public interest
in
keeping that secret
to avail the president of your honor
please
of a free and untrammeled source of
information
and advice
without the thought or fear
that it may be reviewed at some later
time when some grand jury in this case
or some other reason suggest there is
criminality for example
it's very important i'm sorry you did
release him for the grand jury
[Applause]
yes in the president's discretion he did
that
and it's a discretionary matter but for
example the simple matter of
appointments
if i may an appointment of a judge
it's very important
to the judiciary to have good judges
it's not at all unheard of for lawyers
to be asked their opinion about a
nominee
now if that lawyer wants to be sure that
he's going to be protected in giving
candid opinions regarding a nominee for
the bench
it's absolutely essential that that be
protected
otherwise you're not going to get
candid advice now this isn't state
secret
it isn't national defense i suggest it's
more important because that judge may
sit on that bench for 30 years
well don't you think it would be
important if the judge and the
president were discussing how they were
going to
uh make appointments for money
i'm sorry sir i didn't understand your
question but you think it would be
important in a hypothetical case if the
about to be appointed judge was making a
deal with the president for money
absolutely
but under yours it couldn't be
in public interest you couldn't release
i
i would think that that could not be
released if it were a confidential
communication
if the president did appoint such an
individual the remedy is clear
the remedy is he should be impeached let
me give you how are you going to impeach
him if you don't know about
well if you know about it then you you
can state the case if you don't know
about it you never have it you're on the
prongs of a dilemma
no i don't think so you know the
president's doing something wrong
you can impeach him but the only way you
can find out is this way you can't
impeach him so you don't impeach him
[Applause]
you lose me someplace wrong
this is i think what was suggested in
the seaboard case where the court said
well gee if that's so uh then our frog
could be all all covered over and so
forth
uh human experience has not demonstrated
that's a fact very few things
forever are are hidden
secondly however
this case is not that case as i pointed
out there is a plethora of information
this is not a case where there is no
information if anything there is more
than enough
what you're
telling us also could be argued the
other way that there's been a waiver and
neither neither
that is suggested by my brothers i've
talked about waiver i don't suggest my
brother suggested waiver but this
privilege is not like fifth amendment
privilege or attorney-client privilege
where if you let out one word you've
lost the whole thing that would defeat
the purpose of it as we point out in our
brief public policy requires as much
publicity as the president in his
discretion determines would be
appropriate and the more information the
better
and if you require if you rule that
one utterance constitutes a waiver
you're not going to get it you're not
going to have that that thing this is a
discretionary privilege
that the constitution by implication of
necessity
and history has shown is inherent in the
executive function as indeed it is in
other functions
we uh we've cited our brief similar
examples of the legislature insisting
upon such a privilege even against
subpoenas from court
executive
and the courts themselves mr sinclair
you're
cutting into your i know i am
i do appreciate being reminded of that
and i think i would preserve it which i
think is ten more minutes
[Applause]
mr lockerboro
thank you mr chief justice
if i may i would like to advert first to
procedural questions that mr justice
blackman and mr justice stewart have
raised about whether the mandamus case
is properly here
mr justice
we did in our certiorari petition refer
to the fact that we were trying to bring
before the court
for review before judgment in the court
of appeals the order of the district
court
which we said the president had tried to
obtain review of in two ways in two
cases in the district court in the court
of appeals rather
and we gave the docket numbers of those
two cases
and
that certiorari petition was filed on
the 24th
of uh
of may
and judge sirika who was the respondent
as justice stewart properly notes in the
mandamus case in the court of appeals
was served with a copy of the certiorari
petition as he had been served with the
mandamus petition
as indeed had all the respondents who
were otherwise before the court the
defendants in the united states against
mitchell
on may 28th
in accordance with a
motion that was filed in the court of
appeals a copy of which i believe is in
the files of this court
the court of appeals transmitted to this
court the records in both of those cases
the appeal and the mandamus cases
uh now mr justice stewart with respect
to judge uh judge sirika's appearance
here he is a party before this court and
i believe there's a letter on file with
the clerk of this court from judge
zurich in which he states that he will
not appear separately
the united states through the special
prosecutors appearing on behalf of judge
zarika as indeed we would have in the
court of appeals to uphold his decision
in forcing our subpoena
so the case procedurally is properly
before the court both with respect to
the appeal and the mandamus proceeding
i'd like to
[ __ ] where i like to ask before you
get too far up
let's assume you get by the
jurisdictional matters and also the
standing question the intra
executive
dispute matter and we get to the
executive
privilege or get to the merit so-called
which end of this case should we would
we normally start at anyway uh
the 17c end or the
or the executive privilege well i think
normally i think normally you might
start at 17 cn because that would
provide for a
conceivably for a disposition on
non-constitutional grounds if you found
that we had not made a sufficient
showing
to satisfy the ordinary requirements of
that rule so in accordance with the
court's normally
uh
judge uh
that you haven't
satisfied your crime absolutely
what's the scope of our review we have
made the suggestion that uh any
appellate court reviewing this kind of
determination applies a standard of
whether the
district judge who was intimately
familiar with this indictment and with
the 49-page appendix showing that we
submitted in demonstrating why each of
these 64 subpoenaed conversations was
material he made the finding that we had
clearly demonstrated relevance and an
evidentiary
standard and your standard review should
be whether he has abused his discretion
clearly clearly erroneous standard yes
sir what about the standard though
i'm sorry which energy followed what
about the basic standards i think
the parties are in agreement that bowman
dary and iozia that district court
decision established the basic criteria
the government is in agreement that
the standards of iowa must be satisfied
in this case under 17 c well we have
suggested that it's possible that a
lower standard can be applied i'm asking
you what is your position well my
position would be that when you're
talking about a subpoena to a third
party as distinguished from an intra
case subpoena between government and
defendant
uh a lower standard of relevancy or
materiality so the parties are not in
agreement at all well we have suggested
that even if the proper standard is
applied
that we meet that standard because of
the uh the showing that we made that
each of these items
is a necessity standard
necessity
in the sense of being relevant to the
issues to be tried
and being of an evidentiary nature now
the necessity standard comes in more in
determining whether the
executive privilege claim should be
overridden if apart from the waiver fact
and what we call
point claire's argument that
under 17c
you can't possibly satisfy
uh its requirements because you don't
know what's in the text oh well that
obviously we don't think is
a proper legal standard and the courts
have said in fact we go back to chief
justice marshall's opinion in the burr
case where exactly the same
suggestion was made by the united states
attorney in opposing the subpoena that
burr hadn't specified which portions of
general wilkinson's letter were really
going to be material and justice chief
justice marshall applied
with his eloquent common sense of course
not because he hasn't seen the letter
yet but he's made a sufficient
affirmation
that it does contain something material
that at least it should be brought into
court
now we have as i say
uh gone more much further than uh
colonel burr did you think ioza just
means only evidentiary and relevant is
that what you said that's your reading
when you're talking about a
subpoena between the parties yes sir
they talk about other criteria which i
think are really subsumed
whether it's a fishing expedition
whether you're going off on a frolic but
as the later cases as i believe judge
sarika indicates seem to have distilled
that so you don't think nails
and bowmen
requires any showing that this
particular evidence uh
be something more than evidentiary and
relevant
that it be critical no sir i don't
believe so
i think that as you were
suggesting before
and as judge sarika held it's never been
the law that once an indictment is
returned prosecution is not entitled to
continue gathering evidence
the burdens of proof before a grand jury
and a trial jury are clearly different
it's an abuse of the grand jury process
that has been held to use a grand jury
subpoena as mr sinclair suggested to
continue gathering evidence after an
indictment
you apparently can see that you can't
use it just for discovery yes sir and
you say that the evidence you're seeking
by a subpoena you must make some kind of
a minimal showing of admissibility
you can't for example seek something
that would admittedly be inadmissible
hearsay well i hope i'm not conceding
more than i should but the rule does
talk about
uh subpoenaing material from a part from
a person
uh on a showing that it will be relevant
uh it's
the rule 17 and i'm taking a position
which is narrower than of course you're
suggesting mr justice that i might take
but
in all candor the rule talks about
uh subpoenaing
uh documents from a person not not only
from a party mr justice douglas i
believe you earlier mentioned that the
rule applied only to subpoenas to
parties
but the rule specifically provides for
subpoenas to to persons who are not
parties to the case but it says and this
was the clause that we were relying on
here the court may direct the books or
papers be produced before the court at a
time prior to the trial or prior to the
time when they are to be offered in
evidence so there does seem to be some
natural
focus
about
the evidentiary nature of the materials
position because it is a rather
important part of the case yes sir
now we
insist as judge sirika found
that uh
with
citation of chapter and verse if i may
in our 49 page
showing before the district court with
references to sworn testimony as well as
with representations about
what witnesses will testify at trial we
demonstrated why each of these
subpoenaed conversations satisfies
the bowman dairy iozia rule 17c standard
now
that leads me
into the
the related point
what is the relevance of the grand
jury's finding that the president was a
co-conspirator in this case
it has been alleged that we did this
in order to prejudice the president's
rights i think
we have sought to demonstrate in our
reply brief that that was unknown
i don't think it'd be very hard to
understand the relevance of
of a showing and at the trial for
purposes of evidence
that certain people are co-conspirators
for purposes of an introduction of
evidence
but that's a little different question
than the relevance of the grand jury
having
come to that conclusion yes normally
i will concede it is not the practice as
anyone who's been a prosecutor knows for
the grand jury if it is not identifying
the co-conspirators in the body of its
indictment
to
place them on the record it is fairly
common practice however for an
indictment to say in addition to the
defendants the named persons are
unindicted co-conspirators this is not
an ordinary case
maybe so but even if they name it in the
indictment
that isn't enough to uh on which to base
the introduction of out-of-court
statements by a unindicted couple that
was the point that i wanted to get to in
discussing what we call our clark
argument we have never argued and of
course there would be no basis for
arguing that the mere
grand jury finding whether on the face
of the indictment or in the grand jury's
minutes
that the president or any of the other
18 unindicted co-conspirators
were members of this conspiracy would
itself be enough at trial
to warrant the judge's admission of
extrajudicial statements given by those
co-conspirators we're not making that
contention here
the issue arises
because a motion to quash a subpoena was
filed prior to trial
and the basis for that motion was a
claim of executive privilege a
governmental privilege that exists for
the benefit of legitimate governmental
processes
we countered
that apart from nixon versus soreka and
the balancing process
and apart from the waiver argument that
we also develop at some length
this president
as difficult as it was to say this
not because of the evidence but because
of the inherent awkwardness of it this
president is not in a position to claim
this public privilege
for the reason that
a prime of facial showing can be made
that these conversations were not in
pursuance
of legitimate governmental processes or
the lawful deliberation of the public's
business
these conversations as we showed in our
49-page appendix
and as the grand jury alleged
were in furtherance of a criminal
conspiracy to defraud the united states
and obstruct justice we did not rely
even before judge sirica and we do not
rely here
merely on the fact that the grand jury
made this determination we do submit
that for purposes of a pre-trial
consideration of a subpoena that is
challenged on grounds of executive
privilege
we are not confronted with the need that
we will be confronted with at trial in
which we fully intend to discharge of
showing by evidence to the trial judge
that the president and the other
co-conspirators were members of the
co-conspirators
one of your grounds for the
non-applicability of the privilege is
that these conversations were in the
course of the construction yes sir and
we and that
and that
you say is satisfied by merely the grand
jury no sir no absolutely not just a
moment i'm sorry it isn't satisfied
merely by the grand jury
finding
so a court must go on and make its own
determination
if if they were going to agree with you
on this ground
the let me
back up a little i i see the point that
you're making
we are taking the position that the
grand jury's determination is conclusive
on the court
on two issues
a that a conspiracy existed
and b
that president nixon was a member of the
conspiracy that is not enough we concede
to override a claim of executive
privilege because as mr sinclair well
says he is still the president and he
still is in a position to invoke
executive privilege
where we have said we must bear an
evidentiary burden
to the satisfaction of the court is on
drawing the nexus
between the subpoenaed conversations
and the conclusively determined
prime of facial showing that there is a
conspiracy which the president is a
member we made that evidentiary showing
to judge sarika
that showing is before this court judge
sarika found that that showing was
sufficient
and for that reason as i believe his
opinion although it had to be guarded
because these items were placed under
seal
reflects that he did make the showing
that showing or such a showing could
arguably have been made whether or not
the grand jury had named the president
could it not yes sir it could have been
made by as an evidentiary matter
but we already say it was pardon me
isn't it your position that it was
independently of the
of the naming of the president on
indiana yes sir the evidence that was
placed before judge sarika we would
submit would be sufficient to make that
showing and we have said that that is
not legally necessary that we did not
have to make did not have to prove a
conspiracy
in effect prove the whole case that may
take three months to try
in order to defeat a claim of executive
privilege before trial
this court has frequently said that the
criminal process would be burdened down
unduly
if uh proceedings were preceded by many
proceedings
that's exactly what we have here we
submit the evidence is sufficient judge
sirika the evidence this is a situation
in which the the showing that we did
submit intrinsically we submit
uh tracks
the allegations of the indictment and
provides independent evidentiary support
for those allegations
we have said though that it is not
legally necessary in a proceeding like
this for the court independently to
decide whether the grand jury had enough
evidence before it to say there is a
conspiracy or that a particular
individual was remember the conspiracy
we said all you need to find
is that we have shown that these
conversations were in furtherance of
that conspiracy
mr lokovara sir
let's back up a minute that
do you concede that that an incumbent
president of the united states could not
be indicted and tried
for crime no sir you do not
you think he could be
we have not
expressed a position on that mr justice
power let's assume for the moment that
uh
he could not be
would you still argue that a grand jury
had the power
or the right uh
and if so by virtue of what
yes we are today as an unindicted
co-conspirator we do in fact make that
argument
at some level i guess all of our
arguments are made with too much length
uh but we do argue at length sir
seriously
that the question of presidential
indictability
which we
offer some views on just to show that
the question is an open one because of
our obligation we believe to the law and
to the court
is not really determinative of the
question that is really in this case to
the extent that the court
reaches the expungement argument
advanced by counsel or to the extent
that the court does not
reach the so-called clark argument that
executive privilege just cannot be
invoked here
the issue of presidential indictability
does not determine
the issue whether an incumbent president
can be named as an unindicted
co-conspirator by a grand jury we have
shown in our brief why even persons who
do have some constitutional immunity
and counsel argues that implicitly under
the framework of the constitution the
president should have an explicit should
have an implicit
immunity from from prosecution
even such persons
can be and frequently are named by grand
jury as as unindicted co-conspirators
the practical arguments
that may militate in favor of a judicial
recognition of some unique immunity
for the president alone
not for circuit judges not for supreme
court justices
not for members of congress but the
president alone it may be held at some
later date
is immune from prosecution but that by
no means suggests the answer to the
question here
and the grand jury
elected
not to test that issue
the thing that i was wondering about is
that there is only one president
and the executive power is vested in him
and
i do wonder whether or not
the president you said with respect to
other people
would best
the authority and the grand jury
either on his own motion or because of
what some prosecutors suggested
well while the president is in office
to name him as an unindicted
co-conspirator
with uh grand juries sitting all over
the united states
and occasionally you find
a politically motivated
prosecutor
that's a rather far-reaching power if it
exists it is mr justice and there's no
doubt about it
uh
we are conscious of the delicacy of the
issue
we have suggested however
that
although there is some conceivable
opportunity for abuse
our judicial system our democratic
system
is based on
several fundamental propositions
one of which is that grand juries
usually are not
malicious
even prosecutors cannot be assumed to be
malicious
we also assume as this court regularly
holds in first amendment cases dealing
with public officials
that we have a resilient society where
people can be trusted to sort out truth
from falsehood
we have a robust debate
i submit to you sir that just as in this
case a grand jury would not likely
accuse the president of a crime
so too that
the fear that perhaps without basis some
grand jury somewhere might maliciously
accuse a president of a crime
is not necessarily a compelling reason
for saying that a grand jury has no
power to do that
i think the system may
may be vibrant enough
to deal with that and i think the the
inherent dignity of the presidential
office in any incumbent provide him with
a
a notable check against being defeated
or as as a my colleague says impeached
by the action of a grand jury
this is perhaps the most notorious uh
event in notorious case in
in recent times
when the grand jury's action was
disclosed
i venture to say that although it was a
difficult
time for all concern including with
prosecutors as well as other council and
the president and the country
the president has not been displaced
from office he still is president he
still functions all
in accordance with his constitutional
powers if you like it excuse me yes mr
devara i was i wanted to get to this
mechanical question that mr sinclair
brought up
assume for the moment that a given tape
one of the 40 uh 46 is it that you're
asking for sixty four seven four i had
it transposed
one of the 64 tapes uh
is
in fact one eighth
of the total time which might be several
hours apparently because they're long
tapes that one eighth of it
involves discussions of the people who
are under indictment here
but that seven eighths of it
in fact now you have to assume this
includes conferences with the
secretaries of the cabinet the joint
chiefs of staff the chairman of the
atomic energy commission very high level
people and perhaps some staff people as
well
including in those conversations some
highly sensitive material
not sensitive in the sense that it's uh
national
military secrets or diplomatic secrets
but sensitive in
the sense of confidentiality
would you not think that some mechanism
ought to be available that if the
participants are identified
as you've got them all identified by the
voluntary submission of the president
as to the 64.
that if the participants are identified
and the time frame specified
that
the certificate of the major
person's president
that
the subject was
atomic energy
all sorts of other things would be
sufficient to foreclose the court from
examining it in camera
well
before you think so
the answer to my question i
mr chief justice is yes
because these are the procedures that
have been set up in the court of appeals
decision of nixon versus sarika
which were found to be eminently
practical when the
tapes subpoenaed by the grand jury were
submitted these are six hour reels
and under the so-called index and
analysis which the court of appeals in
that case require excuse me required to
be submitted and which judge sirika here
has required to be submitted
a counsel for the president says this is
a six-hour reel
the watergate related portions are
minutes
312. well that's too many 112-146
prior to that there's a meeting between
the president and the secretary of
health education and welfare on a school
bill
after the watergate related discussions
there's a meeting
between the president and
representatives of
the national association of
manufacturers
what has happened is that
white house counsel
has come to judges chambers with the
original reels they have marked the
beginning
of the watergate related portions on
those reels for the court
to make his independent determination
this is watergate related and therefore
offset by whatever
overcoming of the privilege has been
held
and after that is done
a copy of the watergate related portions
are made the judge does not listen
to the non-watergate related portions
which are still covered by the a
presumptive executive privilege which we
have freely conceded from the time the
grand jury began this process in july of
73 to our our briefs in this court then
as to this hypothetical seven eighths
there is you suggest no disagreement
between you and mr sinclair and mr
dwarsky and you on the one hand that's
correct sir and i might say that uh
under the procedure that was worked out
i've this made predate mr sinclair so
you'll have to rely solely on my
representation uh the president
indicated a willingness to allow the
judge to listen to a few moments
of conversation on either end of the
portion of the tape
that had been
listed in this index and analysis as
being watergate related just so he would
have an assurance that
there was a transition from one subject
to another
subject that was agreed to by the
president as being uh
if a minimal intrusion on the
uh confidentiality privilege for an
unrelated subject certainly a
by no means an excessive one mr lockaway
i know you have only very few minutes
are you going to address mr sinclair's
opening argument
that dependency of the
house judiciary impeachment clare
either
should lead the court to conclude
that this whole business before us is a
non-justiciable matter
therefore necessarily that
judge circa's order should be quashed
or in any event
that because of the possible effect of a
decision on the issue presented
upon the impeachment inquiry that the
court should stay his hand
that was to be my last point sir and i
will make it right now
the the notion that because there is
concurrently underway
an impeachment inquiry under the for the
house of representatives
that somehow makes this a
non-justiciable political question
is we think a remarkable notion which is
not supported by sound constitutional
law or by any of the
decisions of this court and indeed i
submit that to the extent that the court
has discretion in the matter
and although this court has
now been given discretionary certiorary
power district courts have no such
option
it would not even be a wise exercise of
discretion for this court to stay at
hand
this case before the court is not a
request for an opinion between two
congressional committees as to who has
jurisdiction over a particular bill
it's not even a request or a dispute
between
cabinet officers or the president and a
cabinet officer
over what proper executive policy ought
to be
this is a criminal proceeding
a federal criminal case against six
defendants
a subpoena has been issued to obtain
evidence
for use at the trial which is scheduled
to begin
on september 9th the court cannot escape
the fact that this is a trial of
tremendous national importance
but a trial that was
brought to a head
without regard to the impeachment
inquiry
this is an independent separate
constitutional process that is underway
and a traditional ordinary prosaic
remedy a subpoena
has been utilized to obtain evidence for
that trial
there's some debate about whether the
evidence is critical to our prosecution
i
i noted in justice rehnquist's opinion a
few weeks ago in michigan against tucker
that he echoed
or presaged perhaps
the same point that judge sarika made
that it's really the obligation of the
prosecution to present all of the
material evidence for the jury for the
fact-finder to pass upon that's what
this case involves
now to say that there will be
public consequences even political
consequences to the court's action does
not mean this is a political question
so that the court
must regard it as non-justiciable
the same argument
would have prevented this court from
deciding marbury and madison
it's common knowledge
that chief justice marshall himself was
threatened with impeachment
if he decided the case against president
jefferson
he went ahead and did his duty on behalf
of this court
later in connection with the birds he
really decided in favor of president
jefferson didn't he no sir he didn't no
sir he did he said it expressly he
surely he surely decided that jefferson
won the case of the battle but lost the
war well
judicial supremacy the the the uh
case is normally thought of as being
solely concerned with original
jurisdiction but if
that's if one reads the case again sir i
submit
justice chief justice marshall got to
the original jurisdiction point only
after he had been very decisive in
saying that a lower court could issue
and should issue and would be obliged to
issue the mandamus to secretary madison
because the president had no legal power
to order secretary of state madison not
to issue that commission he held that
it might be called dictum but it
certainly in the time was a courageous
act but the basic ruling in the case
related to the original jurisdiction of
the court under article 3 did it not i
can see that sir
later however when he did go on in 1807
to issue the subpoena
to a president jefferson
that was an act of profound political
consequences but he stated again
eloquently that it was the court's duty
to obtain evidence if it were material
to the trial
the the notion that
political consequences should stay the
hand of the court is a notion that again
speaking through marshall the court
rejected in cohen's against virginia and
the cherokee nation case where it was
common knowledge that the state's state
legislatures in virginia and georgia
would interpose themselves and defy this
court and marshall
out of the words which i think are
justly famous just as the court can't
reach out for jurisdiction it doesn't
have it has an obligation to exercise
the jurisdiction it does have whatever
may be the political consequences of
that act
the court's action and ex party milligan
and telling president lincoln that he
did not have the power to conduct the
civil war the way he wanted to conduct
it
profound political consequences
come to the war power cases in world war
ii
the japanese exclusion cases this court
did not say that because of the
consequences for the president or
because of the political reaction to a
decision one way or the other the court
should stay at hand
and youngstown
where
our
colleagues brief closes by quoting
justice frankfurters
concurring opinion saying how the court
should as an institution be reluctant to
decide great constitutional questions
but he went on to say
we have an obligation to look into an
assertion of presidential power and even
if the embarrassment to be caused to the
president by our disagreeing with him
would be profound it is still the duty
of the court to tell him when he's wrong
this court
in powell against mccormick
how could there be a more political case
than telling a house of congress
that it had to seat a member that it
excluded but the court said the
constitution for batted it's up to the
court to decide
what the constitution allows
and even though the court interprets the
constitution differently from another
branch that's the judicial process
so separation of powers here or the
notion of political question whether
something is committed to the final
determination of another branch
far from supporting the president's
position demands that the court
affirm the action that judge sarika has
taken this is emphatically the province
of this court to decide
i not to belabor the point but
perhaps the
finest chapter in the court's recent
history
has come in finest chapters have come in
the fields of reapportionment
civil rights
and
the procedural rights of the criminally
accused
would be naive to say that those were
not profoundly politically important
decisions but they were made as
decisions of constitutional law despite
the consequences
that
political branches might face despite
the public reaction the court understood
its duty to interpret the constitution
that's all we ask for today
that's all judge sarika has done
we believe he has done it correctly we
believe the case is fully justiciable we
believe the principles that have been
briefed by the parties support the
correctness of the decision below
and we submit that this court should
fully explicitly and decisively
and definitively
uphold judge sireca's decision
thank you mr nakabara mr sinclair you
have 15 minutes left
thank you mr chief justice members of
the court
in response to my brother's most uh
recent argument
of course sawyer was an important case
with political implications
of course the other cases were in and of
themselves important cases with
political implications
but this case is different in that the
decision in this case will have an
undeniable impact on another proceeding
another proceeding which the
constitution says is essentially a
political proceeding
from which the court is excluded
and for this court to be drawn into that
thicket if i may call it that seems to
me highly inappropriate at least at this
time
as i indicated at the outset
the house committee has made certain
political decisions
the president has made certain political
decisions
they will each have to bear the
responsibility of those decisions with
the american people
this court should not impair interfere
with or otherwise participate directly
or indirectly
in that proceeding
and it's in inevitable inevitable it
would happen
this courtroom wouldn't be full today if
this were simply a
suit on a subpoena brought by the
special prosecutor against the president
even though that would be an important
political matter because the president
is involved
but this is important for other reasons
quite apart from that other reasons
which i suggest
indicate quite clearly that this court
ought to in its discretion and in its
judgment
stay its hand at least until such time
as those proceedings have run their
course
because those are political decisions
being made they should not bear the
burden either way
of a judicial decision well under that
theory all the criminal trials that are
going on should stop then that would not
be the first time mr justice douglas at
a criminal trial was delayed
and in balancing the importance to this
nation i would suggest that that is
clearly indicated and i don't believe
the defendants would be crying very
bitter tears
but in any event the justiciability of
this case seems to me to be the single
important obvious matter that my brother
would prefer not much to talk about
but there can be no doubt about it if
you read page
59 in his brief he says
he the president is now the subject of
an impeachment inquiry
by the committee on the judiciary of the
house of representatives and the
subpoenaed evidence may have a material
bearing on whether he is impeached
and if impeached whether he is convicted
and removed from office
and i suggest the constitution and all
of the history of the framers makes it
quite clear
that the framers
conceived impeachment
as a legislative process the court was
excluded specifically from that function
barbary against madison itself
i agree with the chief justice that it
decided the case in favor of the
president
the rule was discharged and the
commission was not issued
but it also held
and it's been the law since that case
that the courts will not interfere with
or direct a discretionary act on the
part of the president or any other
branch of government and that's been
confirmed in mississippi against johnson
in any case since that time
and the discretion that the constitution
by implication and by necessity
that has been vested in the president in
determining which of his confidential
communication shall be
made public or released is a
discretionary act that this court ought
not by its decision
to undertake to do for him because this
court is not equipped
in knowledge background or in any other
way
to exercise that discretion for the
president of the united states this is
not a ministerial act
finally i observe a slight but
significant shift in my brother's
position
with respect to the prima facie nature
of
a naming of the present as
a coke of spirit
they say it can be made
now that prime it can be made prima
facie i take it that is by examining
the evidence before the grand jury in
order to determine whether or not that
evidence in fact supports
that determination we have invited this
court and judge sarika to do just that
the special prosecutor has opposed in
each instance this or any other court
looking behind that to see whether in
fact
the evidence can be made as he now
states the position
to support a charge of criminality
before the argument the argument was
that because it was a finding or a vote
it was
prima facie now it is i take it somewhat
different
but in any event
a
action by a grand jury
purporting to assess criminality to a
president united states
is a clear intrusion upon the
legislative function and power with
respect to impeachment
as i said earlier the president is not
above the law
nor does he contend that he is
but he does contend that as president
the law can be applied to him in only
one way
and that's by impeachment not by naming
as a co-conspirator in a grand jury
indictment not by indictment or in any
other way
and therefore in this case
i urge that this
court take such action as is appropriate
an overruled judge surrequet
decision
in order that this case be dismissed
thank you mr sinclair thank you mr
jawarski mr lokavara the case is
submitted
[Applause]